please be upstanding for the chairman of
the council
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the February council meeting
a Stratfor District Council I would now
like to hand over to my chaplain Nicky
Justin to open our session with with our
prayers
thank you thank you please be seated sir
right could I just remind everybody
those of you who want to speak could you
ensure that you speak directly into the
microphone and the switch is turned on
and that you turn it off at the end of
your
good one i Corp on the head of paid
service miss Buckland's report list of
countries chairman thank you
apologies you remember Steve from
councillors Dixon all [ __ ] fits up point
eight thank you I now invite section two
members and officers to make any
declarations of interest they may have
in items on the agenda of the meeting I
think that's an ill we now therefore
move on to point 3 which is the minutes
of the last meeting dated the 16th
September December and has been a minor
amendment and that is the Council of
fragile II was in attendance at last
meeting although was initially recorded
in the minutes at the time as not being
in attendance that occasion thank you
and on page 29
paragraph 2 line 3 the requirement on
the regulation 62 of local government
pension scheme regulations 22 C 2013 is
an actual valuate actuarial valuation is
carried out every three years
not every four years take into account
those amendments do we have kind of a
proposal and a second Thank You counsel
fielding proposed a second counselor
Jennings beat everybody - seconded so
are we agreed those are with those
amendments that's an accurate record
thank you we're now moving on to
announcements
first time announcement I'd like to make
is a long service award and that is true
Tina Faulkner who has just completed or
at the end last year 25 years service
with Stratford district council I don't
know if Tina is with us at the moon you
are they want to thank you I don't come
forward and receive your certificate
thank you running
have on tourism and that international
relationship with with China so we don't
then I will go to comes to Barnes but I
attend the council bars its funeral and
then the mera Stratford had a
fundraising evening which I think was
highly successful there was a table of
chains unfortunately change didn't win
we do slightly better than the mayor's
table I attended the marathon held civic
reception and then a second thoughts
production they bear pit theater on
Midsummer Night's Dream attended to the
Royal Shakespeare Company when they
welcomed the Prince of Wales was
delighted to meet Prince of Wales
alongside again with the map then
shortly after that that we the combined
authority the Coventry Warrick local
enterprise partnership and their
proposals new China group which I'm a
member and we had a very very
comprehensive meeting last week about
looking how not only this district but
the Coventry works area can look to
benefit not only from tourism but from
any any trade opportunities with our
relationships built on chain the capital
of the province I've been interviewed
twice on local radio once by welcome
rodeo which was
again to talk about our relationships
with China and I'm sure you all listen
to that with either ears and so you
would be more delighted to find out that
I was important interviewed by BBC
coughing from Warwickshire last week at
the breakfast program and I haven't had
many emails from people about it but
that again was to talk about the impact
of coronavirus and the impact of travel
restrictions on the Chinese with the
local economy in Stratford that was held
at the Tudor barn and I think the
comments I made to that is that whilst
clearly it is a very serious issue
coronavirus to date February is not a
peak time as for Stratford we've had
lousy weather we've got bricks it and
we've got the digging up and reworking
of Henry Street which together also
having quite an impact on any
downgrading interests I've given up the
stage tourist attempt arrive by bus leap
by bus it's very difficult at this stage
to have any comment on what the impact
that was that was why I went on that one
the final point I come up to I wrote
with the agreement of the chief
executive to the city from Joe
expressing this council's condolences
about the difficulties they and having
with the virus and received on Saturday
a different thanks to the council from
the mr. Charlie who's been to strap that
on the number of different occasions but
it was the vice chairman of Jack's
province Committee of the Chinese
Communist Party so they are very
grateful for the support we are giving
them that's very difficult time and we
have tried to provide some material
support in the provision of or trying to
find suppliers of medical equipment
which they are very short of
unfortunately we've caught up a bit of a
short straw and that's at the moment so
just quickly flicking through that was
the ambassador the Chinese embassy
welcomed at all and there's a wonderful
display of Chinese dancers have been
flown over the event we had dancing
dragon the Chinese dragons presenting at
that that evening welcome Radio and
Prince Charles visit and then he was BBC
Cochrane workshop so it's been spoken a
short period since we last met it's been
a fairly normal stop serious events
representing the council which has been
a pleasure to do so I'll now call upon
the leader of the council to talk about
what he's been up to the last two months
Thank You chairman
but I do have a lot of noise
[Music]
thank you
it's just me first thing to report is I
attended the Stratford district council
community Sports Awards and I have to
say I was extremely impressed with when
I saw there the caliber of sports people
we have in the district I think he's
absolutely phenomenal that was really
really impressive I then attended the
non-domestic rapiers consultative panel
on budget proposals which was an
interesting experience then had a
meeting a Cotswolds district to discuss
the global review outcomes this was
about considering the Cotswolds as a
national park and they moved to the
meeting wars no there was then Local
Government Association leaders meeting
held in Birmingham an awful lot of
interesting issues discussed they're not
only planning but also spending on
council budgets then had a meeting with
Paul Maynard of the Department for
Transport regarding wells borne airfield
and prior to that meeting we met with
Jeremy right I then attended a
celebration at the University of Warwick
celebrating the achievements of law
Bhattacharyya the Prince of Wales was
present but didn't get to speak to him
and finally you will noticed on your
desks a notice of decision around the
climate change panel and this is on pink
paper we've worked very closely with the
chair over the in scrutiny and the
leader of opposition from this and in
many ways it actually mirrors what water
district council are doing and we've had
interest in meetings with Warrick
District Council and we have in
principle agreed that we are going to
cooperate on work on climate change
Thank You chair can I just endorse and
say thank you very much for their very
good discussions that we had about these
terms of reference and just to be clear
I have agreed that they call in will be
revoked and I have sent a message to
that effect that we have we have we have
got reached a very good settlement here
and and thank you for that for that
ability to be able to do that Thank You
Ned I'm sure if I pleased to hear that
support for his position thank you
mister make three but I'll make four
announcements firstly I apologize for
the sound system and the problems we're
having at the moment
hopefully David's gone to the server
room to try and rectify them for the
rest of the meeting otherwise we'll have
to speak up so you could just bear with
us for a short while firstly I just want
to make council aware that you'll be
called back in July last year I alerted
you to the fact that the local
government Boundary Commission
due to voter imbalance within this
district are proposing to undertake an
electoral review for the district the
results of which will come in force in
2023 well inform you that I have a first
meeting lined up with him now on the
19th of March which should to help us
understand the scope of the review
following that I'll provide an update to
all members on how that review will will
be undertaken you will also recall at
the meeting the council last time on the
16th of December the issue in relation
to the start time for council meetings
was raised and discussed hopefully you
will all receive now an email seeking
your views about start times for
meetings we also are consulting with the
public to see what would be most
appropriate for public participation so
far we've had six responses from
councillors I would really appreciate it
if you could let us have your views in
relation to start times and then finally
I just want to make announcement in
relation to the appointment to the
position of
the head of community and operational
services delighted to announce that
following the interviews by the
employment and appointment committee on
the 13th of February
Julie Lewis has been appointed she's
currently deputy director for business
at Daventry District Council
Thank You chairman Thank You mr.
Buckland I move on to the council and
that is I fast the death of former
councillor Priscilla cook who was
District Council for the walls burn ward
from 2002 to 2004 and before I proceed
further I just like to invite the lead
of the opposition Council Junod who I
think would like to make a few comments
yes indeed
I knew both before and after she was a
district councillor she was you know I
knew her a long time she was very
hardworking and enthusiastic supporter
of our local community I also knew her
as somebody who always had a sense of
humor and that's quite important to have
in this line of work she was a parish
council for many years and alone our
district has over two years she did make
her mark
I remember her particularly as chair of
new beau Pacey in Asheville as Warren
parish council when the 2006 parish plan
was produced it was an extremely good
parish plan and I remember it being
presented she was a church warden for
fifteen years and a WI member always a
busy woman she contributed greatly and
as I said she had that sense of humor
which was appreciated I know her
daughter's as well and I truly was when
I went to the funeral was it was good to
be able to give them our condolences
Thank You councillor Perry
Thank You chairman as the world member
for was born East which covers the
parish of newbould Pacey and Ashe horn I
would just like to concur with
councillor JUnit I certainly came across
priscilla cook on many occasions during
my visits to the parish council i also
attended the funeral it was standing
room only and it was such a fitting
tribute that she had a wonderful
procession of being taken on to the
crematorium by tractor on a trailer and
it was it was a wonderful service that
actually Priscilla had she'd actually
written it herself and all the hymns
were very personal to her and also the
parishioners and I would say almost
everyone in the village turned out to
pay their respects
god Bless You Priscilla Thank You
councillor Rock very much chairman
everything that said when I was first
elected in 2003 I had been working at
Ashland Hill management College and I
worked with Silla and on the night I got
elected I was astonished I didn't know
she was a district councillor even
though I work with a Sean and after the
camp she was the first person to come
and shake my hand so thank you very much
Thank You councillor Rock so anybody
else have any recollections I know we've
got some former counselors at the back
anybody else has anything which they add
please do so and I think there's words
well heard by all of us here although
sadly I am NOT have no no so thank you
for those recollections so I think I
probably know it's time to move the
following that the council notes with
the regret the death of cancer Priscilla
Cook District Council for the was world
war
period 2002 to 2004 and it stands it's
sympathy to her family and friends in
their loss yeah thank you
I now move on to counselor Peter Barnes
who was one of our longest serving
district counselors the waffle waffle on
Aven ward under various different guises
has it changed its name from 1990 to
2020 just under 30 years service to this
council along of course with service to
other councils in another place so would
anybody wish to share their
recollections of the bonds yes I would
actually
because I do remember Peter because he
was actually elected a couple of years
before myself and you mentioned that he
was one of the longest-serving
councillors on the council he was a
liberal Democrat first then he served
many years as an independent I was a
county councillor I have some
photographs here which it's always nice
to be able to remember somebody in their
prime it you know and I'm happy to say
hand them around if anybody wants to
have a look because he helped to
introduce one of the it was the first
paper recycling service to the council
council in the 1990s when gene holder
was the the leader of the council at the
time I was deputy leader to her and but
what I remember of him was that he was a
community councilor first and last it
was the community that was the reason
why he carried on and I also want to
remind people that he had surely raised
funds not only for cancer charities
which he did in his latter years but the
wallet
air ambulance service as well which he
did for many years and I'd like to be
able to hand sit around these
photographs if anybody wants to have a
look at them just to remind us that yeah
it's nice to see people in their prime
Thank You counselor crop Thank You mr.
chairman just like to sue what can I say
I bet catch the barns what a character
and there's man who said it as it was no
sugarcoating it he certainly said it as
it was a man who stood up for his ward
where he was very popular with his
electorate and he was certainly out and
about on his bike all fallen off his
bike is he used to come to Planning
Committee covered in blood or mud or
whatever oh sorry I fallen over the ride
mr. Chairman I had the pleasure of
trying to keep him under control at
planning committee chair Germany East
Committee I but he was there with his
trusty sidekick max who attended more
planning committees and certain
councilors and probably spoke a bit more
sense in a few more cases as well yeah
Peter Barnes what a character I will
miss in his wise words at Planning
Committee and also mrs. dog as well but
that I don't know thank you very much
Thank You councillor cron councillor
Cargill thank you very much yes I'm just
going to say about max I thought he got
more training out in the most members as
well but that's another story the
funeral
again it was a amazing a pair of so many
people packed in there and some of the
stories especially from there for his
children about herding sheep and
teaching his son to drive a combine
harvester without any training at all
what could possibly go wrong you know it
was just the way that Peter was and we
all have our memories of Peter and yes
you're absolutely right Andy when I was
chair of planning it was interesting to
try and keep him focused on thing as
opposed to his corn dollies while we're
doing this anyway
Thank You mr. chairman I've had the
privilege of knowing Peter since 2014
which is my first time I was elected
here and he was he became my mentor
because I've been on planning I was put
onto the Planning Committee and and
literally from day one he would give me
terrific support not only during the
planning committees but also throughout
the process of some fairly controversial
public inquiries that we had to attend
but for those who actually attended
Planning Committee and those who perhaps
were in the public audience as well
it was always Peter who tried to get in
there first for the debate and the
Chairman's were always actually really
relieved that gosh here we've got a
committee member really diving in there
and that he always said had a lot of
common sense
he was totally passionate in getting
developers to put foot paths and foot
ways so that the children had a good
route either to their school or to the
nearest bus stop and more recently he
was a complete advocate of bird boxes
for every house and those of us who sat
on the committee would always remember
we've got to have bird boxes obviously
Max's little dogs been mentioned and yes
we miss them both very very much indeed
I feel privileged to have a little corn
dolly sitting on my dining room table
because he'd especially about it and I
said I happened to be looking for a
table decoration for a big family party
I was giving and he arrived at the next
planning committee with a little
miniature corn dolly which I have kept
and it still sits on my dining room
table a really special person who was
totally committed to his local residents
through and through I know we all miss
him obviously his family does but I know
Willie's residents in his ward miss him
deeply God rest
Thank You customer accounts lebra much
yes my privilege once again to I've
spent many time sitting next to Peter
who was very good at silence aware very
interesting and lively stories at time
but when the great announcement about
Peter was actually my time on planning
committees when he turned out that the
importance of actually visiting a site
regardless of whether there was a site
visit request or not and he used to make
every effort to go to those sites
regardless and he turn around said when
I asked him why done that he said well
actually said a picture tell you
wouldn't story I'll tell you another bit
I'll always tell you the truth and he's
probably right on that and so maybe we
also bear that little bit in mind but
the other thing is I don't remember as
well it's the way when we were sitting
together at these meetings and that how
openly actually wills to new ideas
despite the fact he was often seen as
bit bit of a bit I would school that and
he would that Jews turn round say
actually never thought about that I'll
remember it for next time but there was
always whatever great privilege of
knowing when Peter was here that was
actually knowing that I was not gonna be
the most scruffy dressed counselor
unfortunately now I'm gonna have to come
on the independent mantle
of ensuring now let em I don't come
suited and booted and I think what would
that to be a real fitting tribute is it
once a year one meeting here we should
have a dress down for PETA meeting in
tribute clothes many years service Thank
You Councilwoman council feeling thank
you I pay tribute to the best-dressed
district councillor always imagine the
agriculturally turned out he was a great
character with a wicked sense of humor
coming in one day complaining bitterly
in the members that he'd been caught
underneath the irrigation system to
which somebody then asked if that was
his annual shower this kept some use for
some time and the time he came in for
planning saying he just had a bath on
Monday was always a great relief max has
always put between him and I when max
turned up his excuse was that max
stopped me talking too much well he was
a great friend that was max his pc side
was quite interesting when upstairs in
the planning department talking about
his agricultural experiences and max
experiences which I think probably
shocked to many people but there you go
that was Peter a mischievous man
r.i.p
that comes fielding Kyle Richards Thank
You chairman I think fear wouldn't mind
me saying that we didn't always agree
with each other when making decisions in
this room but what we did always do was
get on both his friends and as
colleagues he served his presidents his
ward for 30 years in an incredible way
both in an effective manner but also
with a wry smile a glint in his eye and
a fantastic sense of humor he even in
full counsel he would you know he would
always show a joke about the way we were
presented I've put this shirts not just
for you Richards he'd say I've got a new
pair of trousers he'd say all in good
fun it's nice to see actually he dressed
himself better for his lambing than he
did he was he was one of the first
counselors to essentially take me under
his wing and help guide me through my
first two years as a counselor for that
I'm eternally grateful and pity you will
be deeply missed by this council Thank
You council Richards there's not much I
can add to what's already being said
Peter was very much an individual I
think in many ways he's going to be
unforgettable I think one of the more
interesting things was at his funeral
which I attended there was a point at
which we started singing to him and the
music didn't quite match so that
probably epitomized a lot of what Peter
would have stood for I think it is quite
incredible that somebody serves 30 years
as a counselor like many people here I
also have one of Peters corn dollies
sitting in my office Peter will be
missed
Thank You castle rock Thank You chairman
well a number of people have alluded to
counsel about sartorial practices and
again when I was first elected in 2003
we had we had the semi-circular council
chamber then and we're all a bit
stressed the first outing everyone's got
the same memory of the first council
meeting babe formal event so I said to
the council Hazel right well what's the
format you said well just sit at the
back and watch what everybody else does
well I stuck next to council of bars
well I sort of I get dressed up the
important occasion
well I sat next to this chap covered in
sheep fur in a woolly jumper and I
thought perhaps I've got it wrong you
know but anybody we went through the
meeting thanks at the buck there today
anyway it was quite a stressful meeting
because the balance of accounts
politically was tight then picked up
ours was a Lib Dem the meeting was going
on and suddenly he stood up and said it
is going to take like I've got a cow in
calf Thank You councillor all cancer in
Francie Thank You chair Peter was
chairman of the County Council when
Jenny my wife was mayor of Stratford so
you can imagine during that year there
were an awful lot of stories to tell one
which comes to mind was that we we were
at a curry evening in Nuneaton will
Bedford or somewhere like that and after
you had Yukari they have an auction and
I expect all the people to bid in the
auction and one was something called it
I think it was something like a unique
sabre Peter being the devil that was was
pumping up the bidding for it and he was
you could see him deliberately putting
forcing people to bid more and more and
I think eventually went for about 400
pounds
anyway that happened and then later in
the evening we were standing around
having a drink and the auctioneer came
up to Peter and said well actually I've
got another one would you like to buy
this font for the maximum bid you made
and I said to Peter how are you gonna
wriggle out of this one Peter and he
couldn't thank you does anybody else
have any comments
I'm my own recollections I mean clearly
you will recognize from the photograph
I've chose - Peter the the were two
sides - Peters sartorial elegance and
the picture on the front of the funeral
service of him with his chairman of the
County Council chain on was a man
impeccably turned out and I think that
picture impeccably turned out again with
sheep in his hand demonstrates the two
sides of his character he was a rural
man at heart he loved rural issues and
as councillor perry pointed out he's
issues in fact a number of those on
planning committees his keenness for
bird boxes bat boxes demonstrated his
recognition that he felt that we must
continue to recognize other members of
the community the winged variety as
opposed to those on two feet he behind
that rustic exterior there was a
thinking man and the fact that he sat on
planning committees he didn't always
come out with watch might call the
obvious line but very often he'd bring
out points which possibly had other
people have missed about the merits or
demerits of any particular application
and I think everybody appreciated in
fact I know everybody appreciated his
contribution warm words we've heard from
everybody here today demonstrated he had
a
and appeal across the spectrum not just
party but rural and northern we knew
Peter and it'll be it'll be a very long
time before we see another of his like
in this council chamber and it is our
loss that he has moved on but these
things as he will understand living in
the country is all part of nature's tide
and time so I think it's probably
appropriate therefore to move on again
to our formal recognition of his death
the council notes with with regret the
death of councillor Peter Barnes
district councillor for Welford on Aven
ward for the period 1990 to 2020 and
extends his sympathy to his family and
friends and their loss possibly one
little addendum we might make for that
and of course to pull max who will miss
him and we will miss max in this in this
council chamber as well one of the
better informed attendees at training
sessions right we now move on to point
six for your agenda and that is
questions from the public and there have
been two questions raised by a member of
the public copies are the questions
together with the answers have been
circulated to all persons in attendance
counselor a former councillor Chris st.
you've received a response to a question
from the look of it you know your way
around and I suspect you do have a
supplementary question
right on the first of my two questions
on the gun bird settlement can I thank
councillor Jefferson for a direct answer
to a direct question that's very much in
line with what I anticipated but it does
somewhat disprove that the settlement
was linked to the timing of the general
election but as that was a quality of
the press perhaps we should say less
about that today now the second question
that I had on green waste collection was
made with my own personal knowledge and
with respect I've got a different result
here
the answer that councilor Shenton has
provided does not answer the question
that was put he's gone on about issuing
with the work of the Warwickshire waste
partnership regarding the introduction
of green waste charges but that wasn't
the question
the question was have the County Council
the Warwickshire waste partnership
concluded the review that I know that
was started back in September 2017 when
I was leader of the council and I
attended a meeting at Warwick which
actually set that process in in mention
the operation so much as mr. Jensen
might be satisfied with his answer I am
NOT because I want to know what has
happened to the review that the
Warwickshire waste partnership we're
undertaking Thank You counsel
I'm sorry mr. sage councillor Shenton
forgive me it says that we recognize
that a joint which strategy needs to be
reviewed sorry
top and bottom of it mr. st. is that and
the council the the County Council are
very clear and this is from the chair of
the waist partnership and from Andrew
Powe the senior officer very clear so
that it needs to be reviewed and they'll
do it once they've there's more clarity
on the government's new resources and
waste strategy Thank You councillor
Shenton
very nice to see you back in the chamber
as a member of the public thank you we
just give mr. st. to get back to his
chair
thank you we now move on to matter for
determination by the council and then we
have here a notice an emotional notice
now I get to announce in accordance with
the council procedure rules 17.1
emotional amendments or send decision
made by a meeting of council within past
six months can be moved if the notice of
motion is say signed by at least 10
councillors the council has received 10
signatures in accordance with the
council procedural 13.2 this motion once
proposed and seconded can be debated and
will be debated at this meeting I
therefore a call on councillors Curtis
and walk and I'm not quite sure which is
a proposed rule the second two proposed
and second the following motion notice
of motion I would like to propose this
motion thank you George good afternoon I
bring this motion to defer
implementation of the green waste charge
so councillors and the public can have
full and proper scrutiny of the
financial consequences and environmental
impact I've been involved in local
politics because of a frustration that
reasonable views of local people were
being disregarded in a high-handed way
and I'm afraid this seems to me an
example of just such disrespect for our
residents our view does hasty decision
making making taken on the basis of
incomplete assessment of the
environmental impacts and flying in the
face of public opinion in conducting its
consultation the council presented a
false rationale for the introduction of
the charge stating there has been a 60
percent reduction in government funding
since 2020 since 2012-13 confirming
actually has increased from five point
seven to nine point three million yet
despite miss despite representing the
council's financial position in this way
to influence the response residents are
still not convinced that this additional
tax is necessary or desirable and a
six-month deferment would allow better
quality information to be given to the
public and a proper consultation
undertaken to remind my colleagues
public consultation must adhere to the
Gunung principles it is not correct that
there has been a 60 percent reduction in
government funding and councillors and
members of the public alike have made
formal complaints to the council
regarding this statement as a result in
this case I do not believe that the
consultation requirement for quote
sufficient information to be provided to
the public in order to enable
intelligent consideration has been met
further the council must give
conscientious consideration that is
proper rate to views expressed by
residents and to provide evidence that
consultation responses have been taken
into account so has the City Council
seriously sought to address and mitigate
the concerns identified about 75% of
those respondents who objected on a
further way in which the council the
public has has been treated excuse me in
relation to this decision does the
council no credit the decision to
introduce new charges should be seen in
the context of the overall council
budget and it is highly likely that by
June less than four months away we will
know the level of social government
support to the next three to four years
if there are difficult decisions to be
made as a result of possible cuts by
this conservative government then they
need to be made in the round with a full
knowledge of all of the choices we will
be making as well as enabling proper
consideration of the financial position
deferring the green waste tax will allow
time to seek a comprehensive assessment
of the environmental impact of any
changes with difficult decisions ahead
it is essential that we hold the
public's trust and I'm sure we are all
in agreement that the public expects us
to take decisions when we are in full
possession of all the facts possible
alternatives and the views of our
residents I will be calling for a review
of this council's consultation
procedures and processes to help ensure
that views of residents are central to
such future decisions and I do hope
members will support that in respect of
the motion before us today can I
therefore ask all councillors to support
the motion to help ensure that we take
fully informed decisions based on
evidence not speculation and properly
responding to the views of our residents
properly sought and conscientiously
considered to me that is just plain
common sense thank you thank you to
council oppressors come Rock are you
seconding that motion
the stated motivation of the green waste
charges was to get income to compensate
for a forecast reduction in money from
central government since this idea was
put forward in late summer more
information has come to light in stages
in the 7th of October cabinet it was
estimated that just over 1 million
pounds could be come from 40 percent of
people paying so a consultation was
designed to find out what what the
take-up might be and improve the
accuracy of the forecast by the way it
didn't specifically ask what people's
opinion of the idea might be in general
we got there anyway which was
overwhelmingly negative but the survey
did tell us that the taker would be 26
percent not 40 percent generating about
six hundred and twenty thousand a year
not 1 million however despite this
evidence and for reasons which I can't
find any rational justification it was
decided that somehow the take-up will
still rise to 40 percent the number
originally court thought up since
October we've had two financial
windfalls bringing us in money that
exceeded the planning for some sirs when
the green waste charged project started
the provisional local government
settlement of 20 the December delivered
2.2 67 million more than expected four
days after our council meeting then last
month we learned that nearly 1 million
is to be returned to the council from
garage sales another unexpected windfall
and although this is a capital receipt
there are revenue funds in reserve for
expected capital expenditure that could
now be released after cabinet papers of
13th of January shown some of us may
have spotted there has been a general
election recently where a competition
with labor for who could promise the
most spending was won by the
Conservative Party it's seen it remains
to be seen if the new government will be
as good as its word but we'll find out
in June or July
turning to the environment if we are my
if we are to make a change in whatever
sort and we look to all the possible
alternatives to get the best outcome for
instance in my ward as soon as this was
announced priors Hardwick immediately
asked if they could consider a community
composter a nap to the started an
environment Action Team we have a large
rural district there is the possibility
of diverse solutions in times and
villages for all we know there are farms
with anaerobic digesters looking to
balance farm waste with garden waste as
feedstock have we looked at this I don't
think so I don't think we've had the
time we also seem to have had a little
regard to the survey result nearly 1/3
said they would dispose of green waste
in ways that are bad for the environment
if you add up the respondents who said
fly-tipping
burning self transport and abuse of the
general waste bins that's 30% a higher
figure and said they would pay so we
have optimistic assumptions about income
from the scheme pessimistic assumptions
about income from government yet to be
announced but we are intended to go
forward before we know the full facts
can this be wise the delight of the
decision is rational both on financial
and environmental grounds I refer to the
quote doubtfully as assigned to John
Maynard Keynes when the facts change I
changed my mind
what about you sir or madam Thank You
chairman
Thank You counselor Richard Thank You
chairman I think it's best to say based
on the comments that have been raised by
our friends across in opposition that
the policy the Greenwich policy is not
universally supported by our residents
indeed that's been my experience of
crash councils and I have expressed my
reservations in the past however we're
not here to discuss the policy
specifically but we're here to talk
about the the notice of motion I would
approach the comment made by councillor
Curtis about scrutiny an appropriate
scrutiny we did have as a scrutiny
committee the opportunity to review this
policy albeit as part of the cabinet
papers and we also had councillors
Shenton holder come to the same
committee and talk through the proposals
I think it is actually a later committee
and scrutiny is a committee on which so
you've had that opportunity to suggest
that you haven't I think is unfair
although I would say this does
reinforcement come to make does
reinforce the need for us to have
appropriate pre decision scrutiny on all
decisions made by this council I am
pleased of the announcement of the
leader made earlier on about our climate
emergency pavement in terms of reference
which into a pre decision scrutiny
process so I'm thrilled of that and I
hope that that will be continued
throughout looking now at the motion on
notice this isn't a question of
rescinding for decision so we shouldn't
be talking about the pros and cons and
the merits of this policy that decision
has already been made
we're being asked to defer and
specifically to defer a clearer vision
of the long-term central government
settlement to better establish the Ford
financial position which has driven the
green waste charging decision so based
on that I would like to ask a question
either to the portfolio holder also a
leader how if we were to the first day
how will this impact directly impact our
short-term medium-term and long
budget position Thank You mr. Jensen do
you want to respond I think there is
some considerable danger in deferment if
I was sitting in central government at
the moment there are an awful lot of
councils that actually charge for green
waste the government is going to review
it if they review it and decide that
this must be a statute statutory duty
and if I was sitting in central
government those that actually charged
for dreamers collection I would feel an
obligation to compensate if you're not
charging then put bluntly
why should I compensate you so I think
there is a significant danger in leaving
is more exposed I think in terms of our
short-term finances as has been said we
received more money from the new homes
bonus that we might have anticipated
however we have to set a medium term
financial plan that has to be signed off
a sustainable by the section 1 5 1
officer at the moment that is what we
have done now included in the budget is
from 21 22 an assumption that we get
750,000 a year in part to compensate for
the withdrawal of the new homes bonus
over four years that's 3 million quid
we have no guarantee that that will
arrive none whatsoever
I think we are being prudent debbie's
one other point which i think is really
important and I'll pick this up as an
illustration when I was at the
West Midlands combined Authority week
before last
Andy Street was talking about various
pots of money that are available for
investment and he looked straight at me
and said these don't apply to
stratford-on-avon
here in a fluent area and the one thing
I think that he's very very clear is
that the government is making promises
about spending this may not include us
and if you look at where the government
priorities actually are they are not on
the services the District Council's
provide I think that actually we are
being exceedingly prudent in charging
for green waste and I think not to
charge for it will be a problem Thank
You leader councillor O'Donnell Thank
You chair well I think it's actually
good to have this opportunity to discuss
the the green waste charge I know we're
discussing the motion of deferment but I
think it's an ideal opportunity for the
team involved to actually showcase what
the other options were that made you
come to the decision that this was the
best way forward in 2019 a spokesman for
the Environment Department said that
free garden waste collections would not
only reduce greenhouse gas emissions
through less garden waste being sent to
landfill but also see more waste
composted which is cheaper for local
authorities in the landfill disposal and
as you know I've voiced my concerns
raised regarding this charge based upon
the consistent feedback I've had from my
parish councils but my residents are not
alone in being concerned a recent YouGov
poll showed that a vast majority that's
77% disapprove of local councils
actually charging for bin collection on
top of council tax to encourage
recycling I understand that your forward
planning time due to the reduction in
funding from central government and
ensuring that our essential services are
unaffected even though revenue will
potentially be less I also understand
that of March 2019 65 percent
councils charge for green waste
collection but my residents need
reassurance and further evidence that
this really is the best option Jeremy
Paxman course surcharge incentivizing
fly-tipping now fly-tipping and litter
costs around 650,000 pounds a year to
clear from beautiful worship countryside
and other councils have noticed an
increase in fly tipping of almost 20
everyone is 10 percent now as it is
predominantly rural ward this is really
concerning for our farmers and
landowners the count country landowner
and business associations said not only
as fly-tipping a blight on the
countryside but the landowner becomes
legally responsible for the proper
dispose of the mess including the costs
and Deborah shows that while local
authorities carried out almost half a
million enforcement actions the number
of fines was tiny with just over 2000
now locally let's look at what happened
rugby introduced the green charge an
Orange County Council had to find an
extra 100 thousand pounds due to
pollution at both recycling waste and
black waste increasing burning of
rubbish also increased which is damaging
to our environment not the picture we
want to be painting and in Birmingham
whether it's 400 thousand homes only
40,000 took up this Green Green charge
option and fly-tipping has increased
that's just a 10 percent take-up we
can't guarantee the number of people who
are actually going to take up this
option but with the increase in
fly-tipping they also had green garden
waste being put into black bags bin men
abandoning these bags and leaving them
by the side of the road for months on
end surely not the picture we want for
our beautiful prized tourist town which
will already be facing quite a
challenging time ahead if the
restrictions on travel continue due to
infection containment so please could
you take this opportunity to outline the
alternatives explored which made this
green charge the best and most cost
effective value of money option for my
residents as portfolio hold of this area
dish did you wish have a comment on that
please somebody it's something I really
the things that he raised I was going to
cover off later on but on the specific
point about fly tipping when we look at
the the council's around us that have
adopted this green
mase charge and is only Warwick that
hasn't the me these around is not one of
them is reporting an increase in cream
fly-tipping fly-tipping generally tends
to be the bigger stuff not green now I
can see counselor Bromwich sort of query
now but in actual fact it's not just me
saying this is Deborah back in 2007-2008
going back sometime the green waste
flighted number of incidents was
something like 59 thousand for the last
six years that has remained constant
around 32,000 now in those last six
years that's the when the activity
really ramped up on bringing in green
waste charge so looking at the what
deafer say no increase in that same
period looking at what local councils
say no increase in that period so all
the evidence points to whilst
fly-tipping may increase green waste
fly-tipping does not seem to increase
however that's not to say we would be
complacent about this come back on that
the they're just very quickly no there's
no this is factually I spoke with the
leader aquarium City Council last night
and he says they have brought an
increase by an increase in cream dipping
please we do have clear and regulations
out the Constitution to everybody
there is no once you've spoken you want
an entitled speak on one occasion you
haven't got the ability it's not my
interpretation it's actually that set
out which mr. Grafton gotten from him so
can we move on to the next speaker who
is counselor Jennifer actually Thank You
chair
um I believe this proposal to change the
green waste charge is premature as a
number of people across the council are
noting because I don't think it has been
properly thought through as has been
demonstrated by the previous speaker in
the light of the and it's not been
properly thought through in the light of
the consultation from the government
waste strategy which hasn't been
published yet and the climate at climate
change emergency it's quite interesting
that councillors Shenton actually
commented that the County Council has
not completed their thinking yet because
they are waiting for the government's
view to come forward and by making
decisions now is it's just not rational
when we have so much to consider and as
we've just heard we've got so much to
justify to to our residents we are the
collector we have to work in unison with
the disposer and the disposal of green
waste is a major issue in combating
climate change there is an assumption
that not all residents have green waste
needs and that infers that the council
tax is unfair to some residents however
we all have food waste and before
charging for collection of green waste
we should see what the government will
have to say to be cost effective and
effective we should have an integral
system for disposers and collectors and
an integrated food and green disco green
collection and disposal only then can we
understand fully the costs of collection
and disposal not just in cash terms but
in emission terms as well my further
concern is that a 40 pound charge for
collection represents a 30% increase in
AB and E property but for some of our
residents on low incomes who probably
pay no consequence of tax or reduce
council
this but do have green waste and do have
food waste this increase could actually
be more like a hundred percent and I
understand that there is no mechanism
being proposed to take these residents
into account I would actually add
everyone to support this motion we are
talking about a deferment so that we can
fully understand both the financial
implications the emissions implications
and the impact it will have on our
residents in the original consultation
on the proposal to introduce a charge
for green waste for percent of
respondents stated that they would take
green waste to the recycling center
recycling centers are operated by
Warwickshire County Council there is no
evidence that the County Council has
been consulted on how this extra demand
will be accommodated in particular in my
ward the Stockton recycling center which
serves the wards around Southam is
already at capacity at weekends and is
located on a dangerous road where
additional queues would impinge the
traffic on the a four to six if four
percent of residents from the Southland
wards and those are joining Southam were
to change behavior as indicated by the
consultation increased use of this
facility could constitute an extra 300
to 600 traffic movements per week there
is a limited number of other recycling
centers in the surrounding area and
these are at some distance from Southam
and are already busy themselves
suggesting a significant increase in the
use of this facility
this clearly could not be accommodated
either operationally or safely the
implications in this case are a major
investment in the existing site or a new
facility and the substantial costs to
public authorities in the short term
there would be a risk to safety and lack
of green waste disposal availability as
such the risk appears not to have been
considered goes against the principle
to save costs and therefore the
consultation is flawed as such the
decision to implement this scheme should
be set aside until these risks can be
addressed with the option of scrapping
the charge to be a real possibility
Thank You coach Adam accounts the
Bromwich right obviously I had some
issues with this while we debate him
start bringing the green charge there's
a couple of things I'd like to point out
first so I've never lead there talk
about the financial responsibilities and
I also note from the opposition over
there about their green responsibilities
from what's interesting over all this it
has never happened in my time to
councilor I did read my seventh year
this year but we've never actually had
any designated meetings to do it finance
to climate change in particular
now you can assert you're probably
thinking now what's that sue this motion
we are bringing in that proposal
bringing a 40 pound charge because we
say we don't have enough funds in this
council we are assuming that we might
have cuts in government money we are
making a lot of assumptions as somebody
who actually a couple years going to
attended a meeting data to local
authority funding down a house of
parliament it was always assumed that
new funding form that would have to be
found by 2021 because the current one
would not work we've heard already we do
not know the outcome of that the next
issue is we're bringing a 40 pound
charger and were saying we've had a
contract in place for a long time and we
didn't realize that when we're doing our
budgets that we suddenly got black holes
appearing versus council start to be
quite ashamed about that not actually
questioning it and questioning why we've
got these black holes that somebody
doesn't like to go into deficits when
council Jefferson goes on as leader
there about wits is nothing to area
we're bound to move nine million quick
sitting in our reserves central
government is not good
they give us from extra money with big
reserves
yes we're proposal to cut smoke the
medium-term but the downside is and it's
always an anomaly with central
government is that if you are fiscally
responsible your you should punish for
it when they come to dish the money out
now that is probably realistic if your
death counts as North up to Jerry County
Council who were there at the time I was
at the meeting so outside at sea when
they got burst bet you got bit more
money out of the government that was not
really clever thinking I know that's a
pensions for the face every actually
happened that they actually got some
extra money out the government to see
them through at the time to the local
county council told us that at the
meeting but we have to seriously start
thinking what our responsibilities are
for the long term well this forty
forty-five year actually raised the
revenue that's been suggested I doubt it
very much do would it lead to an
increase in a green fly-tipping council
assent and disappears for me but I'd see
green frantically actually great
actually easy to hide I've seen it
locally inside of them in recent times
and that often and the sense we gain
reported actually very minimal unless
people are going out in the summer this
summer they certainly wouldn't know but
they're not walk through woodlands and
by the times ever realize people must go
oh well what's the point
and a lot of people have that attitude
to be honest when it comes to reporting
greedy flight Tippie because it doesn't
have the impact of electrical guns and
more visible stuff we have to save see
also think where do we go with our whole
issue which is through a cloud of
urgency and finance they do go hand in
hand and at the moment we seem to be
going for short-term fixes for a 40
pound green bean charge and that's what
it is it's a short-term fix because we
as a council never debated the realistic
cost of climate emergency along with
finances
and some of you made notes I did I swear
in a question later on to leader so I
thought we actually needed additional
meetings and I do believe we absolutely
do to discuss the whole lot like
everything on the line as much as we
have committees task and finishing
groups cabinet quite simply we're not
going to satisfy our residents through
then small groups now I would suggest
that we do defer this for six months we
do wait to see what central governor's
but in that meantime yeah that meantime
I think we need to seriously also scan
to see let's debate the whole lot
properly finances and climate change and
let's come to a proper consensus in
college counselor Harris good afternoon
everyone nice to see you all the chamber
this afternoon I have to say I compared
with most of the views I have to say as
well this has been certainly polarizing
for many people and entrenchments in
those different views the main concern
for me and as it's well known is my
residents have not been happy with the
decision about the green waste
especially they say the lack of
transparency the community engagement
and they believe and it's been evidenced
here this afternoon that it does hit the
rural communities harder than Stratford
town that said I sought clarity on the
green waste issue and I did share this
out with my community most residents are
accepting or satisfied or as other
colleagues have pointed out they depends
where you sit with the green waste
whether you've got one or not on your
boo but they are accepting around the
finances but for them this is not the
main issue and coming from it as a
different angle their view is that it's
in a pate it was an opaque consultation
total lack of transparency quality
information and information with how
this ties up with the climate
change which is touching on some points
counselor barometers made and again
especially the factor impacts on the
royal community is harder and these
things wrapped up concern them the most
the leader and offices I believe have
accepted the consultation and the
communication can be improved upon I
understand that the leader now has
regular articles in the local Stratford
papers or paper
namely one sadly this is still Stratford
centric I speak on behalf of the rural
communities because this article is in
Stratford Herald and unfortunately it
does not come over to the Royal side of
the district as I say sadly its
Stratford centric and there's much much
discontent about this on our side of the
district - a as it doesn't reach those
residents or help them in any way shape
or form so my request today aside from
everything else that's been raised I'm
asking that the communication with the
entire district be reviewed and we
include other forms of media to reach
the entire district not just Stratford
and I'm looking to the leader and the
council to agree this we have things
like the view social media parish
bulletins we can tap into parish
magazines we also have regular letters
and Mail drops through the Royal Mail or
other systems to all our residents which
can be utilized to include or the
communications in that we're not
optimizing these opportunities I
understand
going forward that there will be more
tough decisions to take and collectively
we all must face our responsibilities
and face up to those but I ask you in
doing this we ensure that communications
are improved so we can take our
communities with us and not have them a
gangster says this is brought about as I
believe it will make all our lives
easier Thank You Charis council Junod
thank you
before I begin can I just actually say
that we did cover finance and climate
change in the task and finish group and
one of the recommendations from that
task and finish group work was that the
action plan should come from it that
would be custard in money and in carbon
and that is to be worked on and it is
certainly was was an issue that what was
was raised but coming to this particular
question this particular item in the way
resource and waste strategy that was
published in 2018 and I have mentioned
it before it was proposed that separate
weekly collections of garden waste would
be offered by councils councillor
Shenton did point out that in the
consultation many councillors responded
negatively but they did so because they
were under the budget pressures that
they currently face government in
response to them also then said that it
will be reexamining the costs and
benefits before deciding to press ahead
we are waiting for for this result it
came it came originally was in 2018 and
it should be coming out this this summer
it is worth delaying the decision by the
district council until those government
intentions become clearer and it is
worth engaging with the County Council
who are the disposal authority looking
at the alternative treatments that will
be available as we move more towards a
resource rather than a waste economy and
that's the what we will have to do under
the circular economy and the 25-year
environment plan that the government is
proposing we have heard that the County
Council will be carrying out a review
after hearing about the outcome of the
resource and waste strategy itself so
therefore again they are waiting so we
we await but we risk alienating support
for climate action if the services that
the public rely on start to crumble and
the environment is not considered as
part of it that we will be asking a lot
of them in future years people
not want just the ordinary services that
they rely on to be starting to be
removed it is actually note o be fact
before I think the wrap-up I am actually
a farmer's daughter and the sister of a
farmer and my sister has had
considerable amounts of tipping not
America but she doesn't even bother
reporting it anymore because it's so
prevalent but what they have to do
farmers have to pay for it to be removed
and it's quite a cost to are on the
farmers and it isn't a small matter at
all it is quite common but it is noted
notable that there is one council in
this country in the UK that L actually
did completely change its mind after
been the garden tax campaign the council
engaged in that did change his mind
after hearing all the evidence was
Edinburgh the party that ran the
campaign was the Conservative Party they
campaigned hard to not have a garden
charge on green waste and they won they
called for and won a feasibility study
on merging garden and food waste
collections and that is exactly what we
already have here we've already moved
forward they were mirroring the actions
of their neighbouring council Perth and
Kinross again with a green waste and
combined food waste collection they won
there and they did and absolutely a
magnificent camping and gave their gave
people a lot of information and I think
it's worth reflecting on that we we do
are moving forward there will be a lot
of alternative treatments coming forward
I note for example that there is to be a
big conference fairly soon about energy
from waste and I know that there are
other alternative treatments being
looked at and people are thinking very
seriously about how they can treat some
of them way food waste that is coming up
and garden waste in order to be able to
make something and make an income from
that we should I think make sure that we
are ahead of the curve
behind thank you Thank You Julie
councillor Cargill Thank You chair right
well interesting what was accepting that
Louisville residents are happy with the
discretionary green bin charge we are in
the minority of local authorities
currently not charging for the service
this is a charge not a tax it's a charge
for a service just like gas electricity
even with a charge this surface will
still be subsidized members were elected
to represent all the residents of
statistics all residents and this
administration is trying to do just that
the administration is acting
responsibilities in trying to manage the
budget but it was getting harder by the
year to balance we all know there's a
hole in our finances in the next three
to five years
and I've got to say the council bomb it
is not a surprise you being looking at
this and working on four years so it's
not a surprise to us at all and we've
been planning for it as well it's not
going to get any easier either and it is
it fair that we have to make these cuts
or the charges perhaps no however the
reality of the situation is that this
administration is being prudent and that
is what we were elected before this
council has ambitious plans to make the
whole district prosperous and of course
we recently recently disc Laird the
climate emergency how are we going to do
all those things you want to do if we
are financially constrained if passed
this motion could do significant damage
to our plans and the functioning of this
Authority picking up the communications
it's a good point
as a society we have more methods of
communicating now than ever before we
still can't get the message across
canvas so as you good point and we will
pick up but just to finish if I'm a
chairman I'm getting concerned
this issue is being used for political
point-scoring so it could eventually be
to the detriment of the residents of
this district thank you John thank you
thank you caster Cargill council
fielding Thank You chairman way back
when I was starting off in the industry
with regards to agriculture
this was BC before Callaghan we used to
put it in the side of the garden put it
in the fence and green waste was never a
problem
there are now two types of tipping one
is industrial
Thank You castle feeling we know we
won't councillor Cleve please Thank You
chair I think we can all agree that we
all want what's best for our residents
the environment and as well as this
council I'm here representing residents
who have spoken against the challenges
and I've been told categorically that
they don't want to the green bean charge
many of them have lawns and therefore no
need of compost when we do not have cars
so kind of get to the tip many are also
on low-income they rely heavily on the
green bin and feel therefore they
already pay enough in council tax excuse
me residents don't understand why they
are suddenly being charged therefore I
feel the consultation wasn't there
enough there were enough and neither was
the information given to them which is
why I support the motion to suspend the
implementation of the green waste for
the six months and request a proper and
in-depth consultation take place and ask
in this time to give all the residents
across across the district more
information as to why the council
considers this to be the only way
forward thank you
Thank You councillor Cleve councillor
Huggins
charging for green bin collections when
we have declared it a climate emergency
is something of an oxymoron the one
thing this district and it's
householders are proud of is our
recycling it was a conservative council
it ingredientes I chling as part of the
services that it provides despite the
fact that it was not compulsory at the
time it is this conservative council
that despite all the other negative
publicity we have endured is always at
the top of the leader tables as far as
recycling is concerned and it is this
council that is investing into a new
facility for rubbish to be recycled the
level of disquiet associated with it
means that this really matters to all of
our voters this is the figures our
householders do really well they recycle
their rubbish at the most people in the
country removing this surface as a free
service is not something that we are
proposing to do lightly I want to assure
all of you shucks before me that there
have been very robust conversations
about this issue behind closed doors it
is to do with balancing books we must be
prudent as we must keep enough in
reserve enough funds to keep the
vulnerable safe which is one of our
statutory duties thank you
I think it's under statements I think
might be the way to describe it there
have been long and intense discussions
around the proposal from minute one
councillor Jensen has been the subject
of significant scrutiny and discretion
by his cabinet colleagues there have
been a number of discussions to try and
look at alternates it's not something
that we wanted we would do lightly and
it is not something we would do on a
whim it has been something of a flagship
in many respects that we've had the
ability to offer a free garden waste
service the difficulty we have and I
think anything that does come through is
communication absolutely could be better
just generally speaking but we have
never got the message across that the
provision of a green waste collection
service is not a statutory service it is
something else we're both and we've
never got that message across and I
think we do need to get that message
across because people are now being
asked to pay for a discretionary service
and I accept the fact that most people
outside of this building through this is
part and parcel of their council tax we
know technically it's not they're
getting that message across but be that
as it may it is a service that we can no
longer in good conscience and with
prudence provide on a free basis given
the way the world is at the moment and
there are some questions about should we
defer that's the best basis of emotion
and there is reference to what the
government is proposing in terms of its
own review and then following on from
that the County Council will embark on a
review now there is no guarantee
whatsoever that the government will
conclude its review in the summer or
even this year so what you are being
asked to consider is not really a six
month deferment because you can get to
the end of that six month and we won't
be in any clearer position around the
government strategy and if we are we
certainly will be in a clearer position
around the county strategy because it
will only embark on its work once the
government has done theirs so we have to
consider where we are financially we
cannot rely upon windfalls any budget
that relies on windfalls isn't a budget
that's worth it so windfalls the clues
in the title and so from a financial
perspective we really don't have any
options
but I'd also just want to leave you with
some other thoughts there are 5,000
flats across the district it seems
entirely unfair that those people who do
not generate green waste sub subsidize
people who are able to afford to pay for
a service I am a relatively well-off
person it is inequitable but people who
who are having to pay 20% of their
council tax because that's the minimum
under our scheme who are clearly in
straight and such circumstances should
subsidize my Greenway service that's
just inequitable and we then talk you
didn't talk about the impact I and I
were honestly saying that people will
will not do the maths and say 40 pounds
for a green waste collection service
week-in week-out come rain come shine
versus the cost of filling your car up
loading it up driving it to your local
centre and doing that at least once a
month people are intelligent and they
will understand that actually they may
not wish to and I may not look paying
for it but actually when you look at the
financial alternatives as individuals it
will cost you more money and and the
final four T's do we really think that
little of our residents that we think
that in their large drives they're going
to stop they're going to start breaking
the law they're going to start fly
tipping everywhere do we not think our
people who are better than that and this
whole notion that we're all going to
start climate change we're going to
start mixing waste and we're all going
to start drive clean up our cars driving
off and then finding some place to dump
the waste in a field somewhere I'm sorry
I think better about people of that
understand and I accept we may not have
been great at some of the communications
but I honestly believe that a large
number of our residents are certainly
going to become law breakers overnight
and is certainly going to start dumping
waste here there and everywhere I think
I think better of our people than that
and it's not anything that anybody
really wants to do 15 16 giving me any
real alternatives other than let's just
put off a port let's put up a bad
decision until sometime tomorrow
one second overcast a permanent one
second over councillor Barker Thank You
councillor Pemberton can have that
second back because not for the first
time he completely stole my thunder flat
owners I just make that point again lots
of flats and yes we did have incredibly
robust discussions about it for those of
you who know that I'm the whip I know
that they were robust discussions
because I was part of most of them so
this has not been a decision that has
been come to likely but I would point
out two things this is a discretionary
service we know what that means I leave
it as that I've had nothing I have had
no complaints quite genuinely from my
parishes and when I say my parish is I
represent on the county a huge number of
rural parishes who haven't complained
about it and all has shifted itself and
one of the facts that seems to be being
missed in this is that food waste will
still be recyclable in the 10-meter bins
that people can have and they will be
able to dispose of it curbside as they
always have been able to thank you hey
counselor Parker
I did a little survey amongst my
neighbors on Saturday morning because
you know I've got the time to do these
things and I spoke to five lots of
neighbors because I had already spoken
to my husband who is not going to pay
for a green bin so five lots of my
neighbors four of them said they are not
going to pay for a green bin they will
get in the car every three or four weeks
they will amass their green waste and
take it up to the tip now didn't we just
adopt a climate change the emergency so
you know Kelsey fielding said it's okay
for people to get in the car and drive
up to the tip and dump their green waste
it's okay for you isn't it fair enough
you you don't see a problem I see a huge
problem with more and more people
getting in their cars and taking their
green waste up to the tip I see that
being a huge problem I also find it
extraordinary that counts the Barker
said she's not had one comment from her
residence really like my inbox is
absolutely fun fact we had one all of us
had one today from somebody all of us it
was sent to every single district
councillor today the other thing I worry
about is that you know we've got area
set out in our district with perhaps
just one Street four or five houses
maybe one of four out of those five
decide not to have a green bit save them
send a lorry there to pick up one you
know we've got to think about this
logically and logic tells me that there
will not be the uptake of the green bean
charge as you think there's I really
don't fix it Thank You councillor Ralph
councillor
hungry chef just a simple question has
there ever been any thought on what will
happen to the green beans that people
don't use about a collection of green
beans do they want to keep them and the
other the other small item I thought
about if people don't want to use the
green beans are they going to have more
bonfires climate change thank you
cancer hunts yourself in counselor Thank
You chair we are it seems by our own
admission affluent and that's great but
then surely that means that we can
therefore afford a bit more time to
dovetail our strategy with the climate
change emergency until we know where all
our finances are and how that's going to
fully emerge based on what central
government they're going to do I just
think well to me it's a bit of a
no-brainer but
but we've had we've had 18 counsellors
speak on this motion so far are there
any other councillors who wish to
comment I'm going to clearly cancel
Kurtis you will have the opportunity to
respond as the proposer becomes fragile
e'en fred has an ear fracture would you
like to speak briefly I would respond to
councillor Pemberton that I pay my taxes
and most of the services provided from
those taxes I don't use so that's
completely forcing what you said the
green bins because we all pay taxes for
services to provide services we don't
all use I too have done a consultation
in my ward and I have to say I didn't
find very many people in support of a
green waste
I even came across people who said well
what are we going to do with it we can't
afford to pay the forward to quit we
don't have a car what are they expected
to do then I'd like an answer to that
please reduce council tax for anyone
thank you
Thank You councillor ian fragile ii as
the penultimate speaker i'm going to
invite the portfolio holder sorry
counselor crop
Thank You mr. Jim I worked in local
30-plus years I know about balancing
budgets and things like that
and cancer Pemberton is quite right it's
this service is a discretionary service
and once you take something away this is
what you started
I'm the problems I think this is where
the major issue is this is where you
know there will be some slight criticism
of the cabinet here from back bends yeah
is that I thought the consultation was
flawed it wouldn't it didn't explain the
alternatives to this as a county
counselor when we've had our local plan
for next few years we actually went out
several loads of places mainly
supermarkets that had a high throughput
footfall and we got the priorities from
there and obviously as I came to camp
saw our major priorities are adults and
children social care and trying to
protect the vulnerable and that's why I
became interested to try and help people
less fortunate themselves yes people
haven't got the same jokes as me as well
Peter ages but no basically to help look
after people less fortunate than
ourselves so this is where we need to
explain the alternatives I know that we
can't keep on relying on the new homes
bonus as part of the budget as part of
any sustainable funding from government
because all the local authorities that
have done that have had issues and life
had holes in their budgets and mr.
Bookman would rightly know the council
has to set a balanced budget by law and
also has to sort out the medium-term
financial strategy for the next three to
five years again it doesn't help that
whatever government at the moment
whatever government whatever color is
always always giving us like a one-year
settlement you know a three-year
settlement plus would again make life
much easier for everybody to budget and
see if there's any black holes I think
we need or needed to have done several
things one provide the alternatives if
we don't do this so if we don't do this
what could we lose and again put those
options forward and secondly I think
when you
to look at the experiences there's been
a lot of anecdotes of friends in
different parts of the country or what's
happened to do with Lloyd Tippin or
husband Tessa I think what we need to
learn from is the experiences of other
local authorities in the county such as
rugby that have been doing it for quite
a while
I'm not eating in bed with see what
they've done what their experiences are
and they flat have come out and said
well in rugby for example this is done
hot potato figures there was an increase
of 10% in fly-tipping
again if we have that information in
front of us I'm sure we wouldn't be
making all these assumptions and quite
rightly I think we need to make our
decision based on evidence again we see
next door to a sport district council
proposing a pound a week on their
council tax via referendum again which
is costly method of consultation and I
wouldn't propose that as a council we
did that but proposing one pound a week
on the council tax to pay for the
climate emergency and again that's a 30
to 40 percent increase on council tax in
warrick district and again now wouldn't
we propose them to do that so I think I
think you know I might be criticized
doing that I think the consultation was
flawed we needed to learn from the
experiences other local authorities and
also put forward alternatives if we
don't raise this additional funding to
replace the new homes bonus which is not
always guaranteed in our budget so
that's my concern so far thank you
cut short cut him off yes country invite
countless sheraton to speak because I
think he's already spoken once cancer
all I discussed with with the monitoring
office beforehand and it was suggested
that if the portfolio holders asked
answer a specific question or a factual
issue arising out of comment though that
it was acceptable for him to respond to
those items I did take the trouble
beforehand to address that with the
monitoring officer do you wish the
monitor officer to comment Thank You
counsel Ralph thank you for your
comments
does anybody else have any comments to
make the Cancer Center now as I've
explained you'll give me opportunity to
be kinder on to comment on specific
items the councillor Donnell raised do
you wish to have as a portfolio holder
on this item the opportunity to make a
brief comment Thank You mr. chairman and
just briefly to to run through one or
two of the the things that have come up
I've made notes of what people have said
can slow down I mentioned Birmingham
well Birmingham is not comparable
because this is it's a city what we
should be compared against is Bromsgrove
Borough Council Cheltenham Borough
Council Cotswolds Daventry none even in
bed worth redditch Rugby West
Oxfordshire and which even all councils
that are around us every one of these
apart from West Oxfordshire and I'll
comes that I'm saying said there is no
increase in the fly-tipping of garden
waste post-implementation every one of
those councils charges where stocks
which I said there was a small increase
in fly-tipping
that deals with that for the
communications councillor Harris
raised a very very good point we have
got a leaflet going
to explain and I agree totally we may
not have got that full message over and
and in nodding to to counselor Crump as
well on all the other councils maybe we
could have put a bit more information in
there but certainly there is a crate
there is a Q&A page on the council
website we have gone through a number of
the journals and papers but we'll learn
that lesson yes
councillor role councillor Shenton isn't
answering questions he's entering the
debate role and using titled
as a councillor to comment on the debate
the issue earlier on was to one side
that's a big question I accept a little
raised by cancer Adama councillor Judith
mentioned Edinburgh but we also know
that Edinburgh looking to push ahead on
a visitor tax that's how they aim to
raise their money there are a few years
away but that's how they aim to do that
you also mentioned about energy from
waste we already get energy from waste
we already have a plant we already do
that just looking quickly down some of
the others before I move on four out of
five councillor Ralph mentioned four out
of five bins in the street wouldn't be
collected if only wand well there's only
one industry well the contract is such
at the moment that we pay for it come
what may
when we get to two years hence we will
have a different contract in one year
we'll be starting to do the procurement
exercise that procurement exercise with
the basis with the knowledge of who is
subscribed will allow us to get a better
deal we will be able to cut the costs
hopefully of the collection and we'll be
able to use smart routing and we're able
to use smaller our Seavey's not the big
inefficient trucks that we currently
have running around
councillor freshly-minted about paying
taxes well this isn't tax and what
alternatives are that's raising funds
councillor chrome mention that as well
car parking and discretionary services
this is one we've given you the other
council's experiences so let's take a
quick run through quick whistle stop
tour through the motion no one like sir
price increases or charges and I agree
that the motion asks for a delay of six
months to the implementation with any
loss of revenue minus cost save to be
paved from revenue that would mean that
waste charge wouldn't be reviewed in its
strictest sense until December at which
if the pump if the government's still
haven't published the plans then I'm
guessing the Lib Dems would put down
another motion delay in inflamation the
implementation even further but the
problem with this is that we would get
to autumn and the main growing season is
over it doesn't take a genius to guess
that many if not all potential
subscribers would think let's not bother
for this year we'll wait until the new
growing season by this time we might
have lost the full revenue for a water
year and let's say that could be 900,000
I believe council a rock said 1 million
but let's look on the other side and say
900,000 well simply that would mean that
our reserves in our five-year
medium-term financial strategy could be
below the 2 and a half million pounds
minimum level which means the section 1
5 1 officer couldn't sign off that plan
given that the Lib Dems also came
forward with further requests for over
three hundred thousand pounds worth of
expenditure you can see that the
professor seconds worse so two seconds
okay the implications of this emotion
could be huge and for that and looking
at part two the motion says they'll
allow a clearer vision of the central
government settlement the Lib Dems
unless the Lib Dems know something we
don't then it's unlikely that the new
homes bonus would be replaced in full
looking at the third element to carry
full environmental impact assessment of
what I keep conscience and by tipping
we've already spoken about and
counselors have had a hundred fifty
eight days thank you does anybody else
wish to add to this debate before I give
mr. Curtis or counselor Curtis re the
opportunity to conclude the proceedings
on this debate right if nobody else
wants to do that accounts of Curtis
Thank You chairman gosh there seems to
have been a great deal of speculation
still in this room about a number of
issues surrounding this problem the
leader commented that the government may
have an obligation to compensate
compensate councils who don't provide
green waste collection that is pure
speculation I do think it is really
important that when we as councillors
make decisions they are decisions based
on evidence and hard facts and not
speculation otherwise we really do our
residents a disservice and there is a
real risk of losing trust a couple of
other points flats have been mentioned
flats have communal green spaces from
which green waste needs to be collected
councillor Pemberton has reiterated
several times that the green waste
charge I agree it is a discretionary
charge is discretionary it doesn't need
to be provided neither than many other
council services leisure centers I go
running on the street I don't actually
go to the nerve center but I accept that
a portion of my council tax goes towards
providing other discretionary services
I'm sorry I don't think that is a valid
argument
- I haven't heard anything yet this
afternoon that has convinced me and I
think a number of other members present
that it would not be prudent to defer
the imposition of this charge for a
further six months we're not waiting
until we know the government's outcome
on green waste initiatives and climate
change we are waiting to find out what
the government funding for local
authorities will be and it is expected
that that will be announced in June or
July at the latest that is what we're
waiting for I think we should wait until
we know the government settlement that
will give us time to look at the
environmental impact in much greater
detail I cannot believe that it makes
sense and councillor Shenton has just
said we'll pay come what may so
currently a lorry if there is one home
one household in a handle it's somewhere
that only one home that will have to be
visited by a lorry to collect that is
not environmentally sustainable
councillor Shenton is also right but yes
Birmingham is very different
Birmingham probably has far less green
waste per household that needs to be
collected it's an entirely spurious
comparison I'm sorry counselor so I
think the deferment again as I spoke at
the beginning it will give us time to
carry out a proper environmental impact
assessment it will give us the
understanding of what the government
settlement is going to be and it will
also give us time to consider
alternative measures at the end of that
period Thank You Sherman
thank you everybody for that
contribution I think more than
two-thirds of you have contributed to
the debate which is I think a a good
sign of debate on this item
clearly it's a matter that has split
views on both sides I would just like to
before we go to the vote
the monetary officer has pointed out
that the proposal is to defer the
decision subject to environmental impact
assessment it is not subject to further
consultation that has not been requested
in the notice of motion that we have
before us so this will not lead to any
further consultation if it is approved
purely to an environmental impact
assessment and the proposed changes
during the deferment period that is
purely for clarification
so let's gentlemen I think we now need
to go to a vote I suspect there will be
looking at the numbers and the
contributions quite a close vote and
therefore to a naval officers to carry
out the count clearly that any gray
areas I get I'm going to ask you to keep
your hands up until I've said thank you
on that item and I said and high so we
can see so we have a motion it's been
proposed and seconded we have no
amendments to that motion therefore all
those in favor of the motion please will
you put your hands up hi
keep ma please thank you great hands
down all those against the motion please
put your hands up thank you do we have
any abstentions
we have no abstentions there were 12
votes in favor of the motion
there are 19 votes against the motion
therefore the emotion the motion is not
carried but I would like to thank
members for a detailed and comprehensive
debate I think all areas were covered
and I think all views were given a good
airing during that motion before cancer
Rolf leaves I am going to propose a
brief moment to adjourn the meeting then
we have 5 minutes
hello hello hello want to not fold it
back now
this one heart this is okay this is okay
it'll be nice to see what's that what's
the evil word you're going to give me
yes I don't I don't I said I say no I
know because I'm not my channel you know
on the right channel no now I'm on the
right channel
was this one like this one
the time
but let us recommenced the meeting
consolation family if you go outside
right
they were mister first start this next
item we'll move on to item 8 which is
the council budget and I write the
leader of the council understand
[Music]
which seems to be the prime minister to
the significant we actually do that's
why in terms of the NHS in Scotland some
services so preparing a medium-term
financial strategy is not being simple
three forms of funding we get our
revenue support business rates retention
we had 3.7 million in 2020
we know we know well even with the
actions we've taken today the decision
to carry on charging for green waste the
likelihood is we'll need to find another
2.5 to 3 million
we have the budget for 2021 and the
medium term financial strategy provide
yes it was October actually the prime
minister and we still the Prime Minister
announced at the Conservative Party
conference that austerity was over we
were told that there would be an end to
policy the policy of cutting public
spending and actually I quote we were
told that the council's would be at the
front of the queue for new funding and I
quote austerity is coming to an end yet
today we're still waiting news from
government about core central government
funding we're facing a council tax rise
a 3.5 9% 5 pounds to 144 pounds 12
pence for a Bundy property and are
cutting services alongside that as well
and this council is actually one of the
lucky ones still able to live on some
reserves from the past there were fifty
million pounds at one stage in the year
2000 and with an understand of three
hundred and seventy nine thousand the
leader statement is actually hardly a
warm endorsement of his own government
somebody actually needs to tell the
Prime Minister some truths just what the
recent delay in announcing the local
government finance settlement is doing
for future budget settlement and
planning local authorities need to be
able to set longer-term budgets with
three or four five year time horizons to
achieve greater certainty more
flexibility in how they manage their
budgets between years the government's
distant decision to delay the
implementation of the fair funding
review and a four years of a spending
round has meant a great deal of
uncertainty and we have to date no
indication of what the future will look
beyond the next 12 months someone needs
to tell the government that local
councils have to meet the expectations
of their residents ensure that
vulnerable people are not left without
resources
and meet the demands of the emerges
climate emergency and on the climate
emergency the legislation has placed
specific responsibilities on councils
and I'm glad that we are stepping up to
the mark here at Stratford but we also
need to continue delivering local
services we risk alienating support for
what we will need to do under climate
action if the service of the public rely
on start to crumble around them we have
we've had also another delay as I
mentioned earlier on the roads or some
way strategy if this was published in
2000 in December 2018 so quite some time
ago we need to embrace new technologies
in both services in the built
environment but councils have been
hindered by weaknesses unhelpful changes
confusions in planning regularly
Asians we're still waiting for the cult
for sustainable homes we need to
consider what councils can realistically
do under adaptation planning and again
this race is critical importance of both
capital and revenue resources and
government is leaving us in the lurch we
need to see a willingness and I would
suggest by this council to hold the
government speak to fat to the fire and
ensure that their rhetoric max that
matches reality our communities of
localities deserve better than the way
that we are being treated as councils
the way that are being treated by this
government in areas for the local
authorities Standing Orders England
amendment regulations this debate will
so I now invite to Council Trevor Harvey
to introduce this
Thank You mr. German this is the first
time I've had the privilege of speaking
in support of a proposal for a budget
for this council I've been struck by the
thoroughness of the debate and challenge
to which these proposals have been
subject during their formulation the
context for that preparation however has
been one of the considerable uncertainty
about the future over local government
finance would you have the benefit of a
four-year settlement review during 2019
wait for another year we're waiting for
the outcome of the fair funding review
and to learn what the government intends
to do about the future of business
rating retention and it's possible
reform what we do know from the spending
review announced last September however
is that local government at district
level is not one of the government's
highest priorities we know that the
government's priorities lie
understandably with meeting the needs on
social care and health care generally on
education provided in schools and
colleges and on making people safe
through the reduction of crime none of
these areas of responsibility lie with
District Council's there's every
prospect therefore that the fair funding
review will create winners and losers we
all know that the support for this
council from central government has
declined over recent years and with the
exception of new homes bonus and we know
that new homes bonus will disappear as a
source of revenue over the next three
years whatever comes out of the next
four year spending review three things
are predictable first that whatever the
government decides district councils are
likely to receive less second
there'll be an increasing need for the
cost of local government at district
level to be locally third that central
government as is evident from the case
bail out any local authority that takes
poor financial decisions over its
finances now it's open to councilors to
disregard these facts in the obvious
trends they demonstrate it's possible
that some of the best foresighted
counselors may be prepared to delay who
procrastinate over difficult decisions
but the budget proposals involve but I
suspect that the more alert and informed
of majority of counselors will be alive
to the issues at stake they all want to
protect the council's capacity and
capability to provide the level and
quality of services that our residents
need over the longer term and they all
want to vote to approve the budget
proposals as presented the long-term
soundness of the council's finances is
our the bedrock of its ability to meet
our residents residents expectations the
budget proposals are designed to do just
that deferring tough decisions now
almost always leads to even tougher
decisions later I therefore propose that
the recommendations 1 to 5 set out on
page 30 are approved Thank You mr. chair
thank you very much councillor Harvey
I'm now going to invite the leader to
propose that we approve the budget house
of saud pages I propose that we accept
the recommendation Thank You councillor
Jefferson thank you we have a proposal
which president seconded
caz a JUnit you're indicating that you
wish to propose an amendment to that
yellow piece of paper which is the
Liberal Democrats amendment to the
budget I just want to start by saying
actually there are some things in the
conservative budget that I support the U
bus service for example is something
that I feel that is needed but I do
believe that it needs a review to make
sure that it serves a wider area than it
possibly does at the moment I also
support the investment into active
children's play in the park next to the
Hopkins precinct in all Ulster it's
actually owned by the District Council
but it has missed out on investment for
so many years I don't think it's ever
really been properly brought up to date
since I moved into Ulster now our budget
puts forward some solid proposals one of
which is that advices it should be made
available by the Citizens Advice Bureau
to residents outside the Town of
Stratford upon even I as a councillor
represent award one with one of the
highest deprivation indices in the whole
of South Warwickshire I see the need for
accessible citizens and advise services
outside stratford on a regular basis
not everyone can travel into the town
here easily and they certainly can't do
it cheaply if they rely on local buses
the fares are quite considerable the
none climate change one of the lessons
that I have learnt in my professional
life is that change such as that is
meeting is needed to meet the challenges
ahead
do not come by threatening cuts we need
to continue to deliver local services
I've said it before we risk alienating
support for climate action if the
service is the public rely upon start to
crumble around them being able to show
the coal benefits of change is essential
the community climate change fund that
we are proposing is a way of raising
awareness is a way of engaging
communities each a way of showing the
benefits low-carbon technologies and
behaviors and is on top of the 500000
that is in the main budget which I also
support given their set into your head
it is essential that any one-off funds
received by this council such as that
from the state of former council garages
should be used to see strategically
we're asking that this one-off function
support affordable housing and community
projects and there is a precedence to
this there was this is exactly how the
form of one of funding was used in 2017
in 18 it was a sum of 1.4 million from
previous sales was ring-fenced by this
council for temporary accommodation
building on this we proposed a move-on
Support Fund to achieve successful
support for support for formerly
homeless residents the homelessness
proposal seeks to develop ways in which
people can be supported beyond the
temporary accommodation after becoming
homeless
there will be varied needs requiring
assistance from trained support workers
all business rates collected from
renewable energy projects including so
anaerobic digestion or wind is retained
by local government there is no 50%
allocation to central government in
Shropshire Council from this year
onwards 20 2021 all such business rates
from renewable energy projects are to be
ring-fenced to support climate change
initiatives South Cambridgeshire
District Council took a similar approach
last year 2009 to 2013 the business rate
income from a solar park to a climate
change Community Fund and this is a
pointer that this government - this
council that the government allows a
similar approach to be used here and on
the on the climate change I would also
urge that a climate change officer which
is one of the things that was proposed
in the task and finish group does is
moved on as quickly as possible we do
need somebody to lead on making sure
that we have solid climate change
proposals put forward the Hopkins
precinct proposal is to improve the
chance of the chances of the local
community being successful with bids to
top up the amount already in the budget
to seconds of June a quote from a play
area does indicate that some more is
required they've expressed a wish that
they do not want to compete with the
Greg Hall proposals to raise money and
they are will be competing specifically
for funds that will be for play areas
and for sports thank you Thank You
councillor Junod that's all proposed
amendments do you have a seconder for
that proposal Thank You Adam we
therefore have a proposed and seconded
amendment to the motion
the training session a few weeks ago
given by the Citizens Advice they work
closely alongside this District Council
and orbit they are a charity relying on
grants which have been severely depleted
by the last few years the current
project is funded by the trust the reach
out and help project targets those in
crisis through a comprehensive home
visiting and advice service by visiting
residents in their homes they overcome
barriers that exclude them from the
services they need to quickly gain trust
and reach the root of the problem in
delivering this project Citizens Advice
are providing a fully accessible and
inclusive service targeting supports
some of the most vulnerable people in
strap the term of points of crisis in
their lives advisers aim to maximize
income through claiming benefits such as
pet and universal credit energy saving
advice claiming hardship grants support
access to health and social care
services access to support groups in all
improving their lives substantially the
project currently runs four days a week
in Stratford and has supported over 200
people with over a quarter of a million
pounds worth of additional income
identified this hazard effect reduced
isolation and improved affording social
Social and Health Care Services and
securing sustainable living conditions
as I said earlier both districts in
child funding comes to an end in June
and although Citizens Advice have
applied for a National Lottery Community
Fund grant
Citizens Advice will not know whether
they have been successful until the
money runs out citizens are looking to
cover the district including some
peripatetic network currently only
provided office based they're keen to
use community based buildings in the
district to do this valuable work but
may not have the money to do it not only
will the money potentially run out but
there may be no funding for this service
to operate across the district
these are vulnerable residents in all of
our wards here who will not have the
benefit of Citizens Advice skilled
advice advocacy to those in need will be
lost fifty thousand pounds is a very
small amount of money in the grand
scheme of things and looking at David
here but without it these vital services
will be lost and certainly some of your
residents will suffer because of the
lack of funding nearly a million pounds
and solar garages will be going into the
general pot so fifty grand is not going
to make a big dent at all I would urge
you all to allow this one of payments so
that we can look after some of our most
vulnerable citizens thank you thank you
Castle Rock thank you I just wanted to
add to a few points that cancel a rough
night because I too went to the training
session on Citizens Advice bureaux and
it was a sales pitch as far as I was
concerned and I think one point I would
add to cancel a Rolf's speech it's an
element of self funding and the officers
that were there from our council didn't
disagree with what was said in CIB are
able to leverage funds from all sorts of
other bodies that actually ends up
saving this council more money so this
amount of money that is in this
amendment would end up and I've got to
believe what was said and the council
officers we had there didn't disagree
with this the benefits that are obtained
from all sorts of other sources as a
result of the activities of CIB ended up
saving this council money but in various
ways so I would commend that strongly to
this council to think about something
that was said you can cause we could do
a bit of research over it in the east of
the district and I went to it's in the
library actually the service centre down
they've got a terminal that you can
access the services here without
officers having to travel and you can
you can you know I've pretended out with
somebody they wanted to just to speak to
God and serve you and you do it through
the German or not and I would also
congratulate the web we've involved in
something that out because it's quite
good that we don't have to trouble to do
that but interestingly the CIB services
in the Eastern District are provided by
rugby CIB but there's no reason why that
the funding can't be exchanged so I
would strongly recommend that particular
amendment has been a self self-funding
thing and what they put in here if we
could do that as a trial the other thing
I would point out is the business rate
retention for renewable energy
it's quite clear if we get something in
as a result of renewable energy benefits
let's keep it for a new ballon G we've
done the climate change emergency motion
if we get something air in renewable
energy let's keep it in your language so
it works so I'll just pick those two
things there thank you very much for
listening chairman thank you thank you
councilor rock castle bromwich first of
all quick correction of nerds council
add CA b services east of district south
actually paid for by south and town
council that things yeah we don't have a
kitchen please
so this then goes on some house which is
very relevant on this this event with
here actually just offer books to us at
the east of this district again of this
and actually I've seen this is a trend
over years and I'm gonna be a bit
critical lib dems here because I can't
remember too many times they've had she
ever come up with too many proposals
east of the end forty that's partly that
I can't support this because as
certainly see they're members of the
cabinet and the leadership now I've had
many meetings over the past couple years
we've discussed the needs of areas which
are in deprivation and what slows in the
in the whole of the country and we've
discussed ways forward and we still
continue discussions on this what it's
all very fine at the moment saying yet
we can do one off payments here there
next thing I can stand here I'll give
you a list of all the things I'd like
the sound I'd surrounding villages as
I'm sure the local councils around now
we start getting too dangerous totally
for one-off projects which then comes to
the bigger issue to discuss how we turn
around and make sure that were looked
after and it's not through a budget
amendment it's actually fitting properly
that can't be decided as such today
that's something we need to have proper
debates about what we do know is should
we go ahead and do this next year don't
come never wishlist and then they're
coming up with wishlist year after
because that's the nature now of people
whether it's from live down to annex
from Independence now but if we start
just talking real specific schemes in
this budget we are opening a can of
words we are meant to work together
it's called Stratford district council
and we have to hold this straight yes we
might all have very good project ideas
but that's why we should throw them open
to talk and see what's affordable each
time round and we've got to seriously
start thinking as councillors not just
engage in one section of our district
but bringing it all together and working
out how we try and benefit every single
person in this district and the public
become aware that we are working to
benefit every single person in this
district so for that reason I cannot
support the amendment although that's a
vehicle proposals by thing we need to
have a large debate on these sorts of
things Thank You councillor Bromwich
councillor Pemberton Thank You chairman
Thank You councillor Roman I have to say
I think your point is well made that we
shouldn't be using the annual budget
round as part of a bidding war for our
various pet projects whether they be
founded on the town or across the
district we need to if we want to bring
forward projects we need to do the hard
thinking on this stuff and we need to be
bringing that forward through the
municipal year so I struggle with some
of these things where they're dropped in
and you can't plan from and we're
talking about trying to be more
strategic and to be more effective in
our budget making process and this kind
of approach cuts across that I'm gonna
make some comments on
some of the items here it turns off the
Hopkins preset I'm fairly certain that
there is another route to achieve this
through section 106 monies that are
available and I'm quite happy with Casa
Laguna because I've had some
conversations with cancer the barometer
utilizing and repurposing section 106 mu
so I'm fairly certain I can close that
10k out for you with that and I'm happy
to take that up separately with you
because I'm fairly certain that there's
a way of doing that because I think it
is not an unreasonable point that he's
made that Hopkins precent has over the
years not had and some of the
investments that I think it would be
reasonable to expect but I think that
this is the wrong way of going about it
and I think we can take offline and find
a solution for that I want to address
two other items firstly is the one off
one hundred and fifty thousand pounds
for homelessness support moving on from
the Fred winter project and again I'm
going to go back to we've got to do the
hard thinking about this we are going
through the process and it will be
subject to a planning application for
the establishment of the Fred winter
project in the town which like should be
quite a groundbreaking multi-agency
approach to tackling homelessness and if
we get it right and we're confident in
the partners of it though it will be got
right this will be the kind of thing
that other authorities will be copying
up and down the land now the thought
about what happens next is already
within the thinking of the people have
been putting fred winds together and
this authority and I would say this
falls under that we need to do the hard
thinking bit first of all there may well
be a point further down the track where
we can put some kind of project together
about what happens next
but the Federative project hasn't even
been it's planning approval yet so we
are just too early in the cycle for that
so I'm struggling with seen
as something we should be putting in
right now nor do we have the engagement
with the partners to understand what the
shape of that follow-on should be
because it will be different from what
we've done in the past because the entry
point which is Fred winter is different
to what we've done in the past and the
final one and I'm sorry guys this one
really gives me a big problem and it's
the clock it's the community climate
change fund and I'll tell you why it
gives me a problem members does anybody
want to take that timing is everything
in this webcast legit
right and we're back
are we ready okay so I'm just it's been
which we reckon circa may 2021 for the
opening of the Fred winter project
subject to its planning permissions so
the things got to run through so let's I
think we competitor the climate change
fund is the one that gives me a problem
and the reason it gives me a problem is
we all stood in this chamber or sat in
this chamber we all took part in a
debate and we all said climate change
the climate emergency and this is not
something that of you know is a party
political thing it's a thing we've got
to get done and every single person in
this room knows that 500,000 pounds
isn't the right answer because nobody
knows what the right answer is we start
with a number that is a starting point
and we should not and if we're going to
get into a bidding war every single year
about oh let's put something else in
we're not going to engage if we want to
have a position where we have some form
of community community group fund I
think that's something for the
soon-to-be setup panel to think about in
terms of a priority but it should be
within what we've already set aside
because further down the track we will
be moving that number on but if we move
that in the branches because every year
we've got a project we're never gonna
have any real coherence about this thing
so if if if there is a feeling that this
fund is something that's a big-ticket
priority for climate change and I'm not
sure there it is and I think it'll be 15
people to work then let's work it
through through there and then let's
have a strategic view about in the
future what the correct number is for
what we put aside so where I'm at at the
moment can't support the 150k can't
support the hundred K can support the 10
K in particular and generally just can't
support the whole lot Thank You cousin
councillor cargo thank you and it's
interesting because there's some good
points in here exactly the same thing we
know you saw this on the day of the
budget discussion and echoing cancer
Pemberton there we need to have a look
at some of these things
because I'm quite good points and we do
it somewhat differently at County who
actually will look at friendly
amendments and suchlike and bring them
forward because there are some good
points picking up the see a citizen
device a couple years ago two years ago
now and they just abruptly pulled down
to bolster on the outreach program there
i took me a year with others my
colleagues to actually get it back again
we have had it for a year now they are
now restructuring and i know they're
going to come forward with a proposal
plan and i would rather say that before
we start launching some money into it
but in principle i do agree with you
because of his vital valuable service
for us all I'm not going to carry on any
and Michonne gets cancer Pemberton they
said all the same things I was going to
pick up if we can see some of these
things beforehand you know I'm just
asked to the mind counselors that these
proposals were considered by the budget
task and finish group and were presented
to cabinets at the last cabinet meeting
so for clarification they have this is
sorry mister sorry cuts of Cargill that
they have been okay thank you to counsel
Riley Thank You jr. I'd just like to say
that in particularly the climate change
fund
we supporting this amendment thank you
Thank You councillor Riley councillor
Adam Thank You chair just brief note has
a member representing Ward in the far
east of the district I think it's a this
amendment due to district wide
initiatives not simply this side of the
m-40 particularly in terms of garage
sales this is something which I have at
least two of in my ward and I know are
numerous across the district
these garages being sold are in areas
that often made up of social housing
already and areas that do need further
investment in this I think it's
important that we use this funding that
can come from this to invest in the
services that we can provide as a
council in the areas that they are
needed but on top of that I think it's
important for the visibility of this
council to be shown to using the assets
that used to be completely under our
umbrella to actually take from those and
put back into the community and not
being seen to do so can reflect
negativity and that's something I've had
already from comments from residents and
that's why I'm supporting this item as
well as the amendment thank you thank
you do we have any other councillors who
wish to seek clarification council
members of council Kempton speak again
following in which case I might cancel
Tony Jefferson to speak on the amendment
Thank You chair when it's time for that
mission I agree which made
serious point I would agree with counsel
Abramovich there is a danger that some
of these could actually turn into money
will spend given the way these are
phrased I agree with my colleague
councillor Pemberton on item three on
homelessness I agree with it with him on
the community climate change fault I
mean the reality is in that we've
already put aside 500,000 for it we
don't know how much it may cost and one
of the issues with this is that when is
government funding going to come down
the track to enablers to take some
climate change initiatives I have to say
as well I think ring-fencing receipts
may not necessarily be a good idea
because who knows what options therefore
I am opposed to these amendments thank
you Cassie Jetson so we've had them
remember proposed a second did we've had
a debate nobody else has put their hand
up to speak on the debate it's an
amendment and I have checked on that
cancer unit nobody else wishes to speak
on the amendment we therefore have to a
vote on the amendment the amendment
obviously includes fire are six
different proposals
it is a recorded vote now it is a
council council Juno deters proposals
proposals option as to whether you wish
each amendment to be voted on and a
recorded vote separately or whether you
are prepared to take an on block vote
for all six items or anything in between
I'm sure that can be arranged if you
wish
a brief period would you like to suggest
how would like to go forward I'd like a
separate boat on every one of them
because there is different levels of
support for different ones within this
within the proposals Thank You captured
unit in which case we will need a
recorded vote on each six each of the
items okay right so we will be holding
six separate recorded votes starting
with the boat in relation to decisions
and advice panel reach out program
supported fifty thousand pounds in 2021
now I'll be called an hour every
councillors name against the bridge
kozlak are you because I please just
look Crump catch the courteous ghost
like Eddie Kessler fielding
councilor Fleming councillor Pullman
Council of France Li Ian councilor
Pressley Jenny Khosla Harris Kessler
hobby Kessler hench's everything Kessler
Jefferson councillor Jennings absolute
Junod just like Kendall council Mills
against coastal O'Donnell just look
Perry Kessler Pemberton capsule of
Richards customer Riley comes with a
block cash Lyubov cashless Shenton go
Wally Huggins
okay so there were eleven votes yes the
proposal 20 votes against therefore that
particular moment is lost will now have
a second vote in relation to the
community climate change fund we're just
making sure we're life it's paper to be
honest so this is to provide one-off
funded their one hundred thousand pounds
in 2021 again you'll be us vote for or
against against Kessler Adam counselor
Barca casterbridge Khosla Cargill
Kessler Cleve Tesla Crump Khosla Curtis
let's let ed in Tesla field in counselor
Fleming counselor Foreman counselor
freshly Ian counselor Ginny Kessler
Harris Kessler Harvey as the hinges
heavy Finn have such a foursome
Kessler Jennings Tesla's unit that's
like Kendall Castle Emile's
O'Donnell has Lipari Tesla Pemberton
after Richards Kylie
Kalibak central wolf council Shenton and
celeb Wally Huggins it was votes against
move on support the same routine if we
can start with counselor against
counselor Adam catch the Barker cut the
Bromwich castle Cargill cancel cleave
cancel Crump
councillor Curtis just let Evan Kessler
fielding counselor Fleming Kessler
Foreman cancel the frenzy Ian and it's
like fresh Steve Ginny caster Harris
Kessler Harvey Kessler hench a Seraphim
Castle Jefferson Thank You Jennifer
Jennings
how's the JUnit counselor chemical
Kesler mills kessler terminal cancer
Perry Hassler Pemberton Council of
widgets
Gessler Riley Kalibak counselor both
camps of Shenton and council of Wally
Huggins okay I can do that math squad
quickly on that one who's 11 for 20
against the Fourth Amendment is in
relation to the Hopkins precinct it's
named pay area
I think that's presumed to be play area
the support of 10,000 pounds in 2021
so again against counselor Adam Custer
Barca counselor plumage counselor
Cargill
Castle cleave the silence come on
counselor Crump counselor Curtis just
let ed in counselor field in counselor
Fleming that's the foreman Chancellor
freshly Ian Chancellor freshly Jenny
just let Harris
that's not Harvey counselor hint your
Seraphin counsel Jefferson James
counselor Jennings counsel JUnit
counselor Kendall counselor Mills
O'Donnell counselor Perry
that's the pemberton counselor Richards
just look Riley council Rock has Lyubov
counselor Shenton in counselor Wally
Huggins
okay so in total there were ten votes
for for abstentions and 17 against talks
about bringing fencing garriage capital
receipts for community housing schemes
against Kessler Adam Kessler Barca
counselor Bromwich Tesla Cargill because
like leave counselor Crump
hence the courteous Cussler ed in
counselor field in counselor Fleming cuz
the foreman kazlik Leslie Ian and
selfishly Jenny
cuz the Harris Tesla Harvey as they
enter Seraphin cuz the Jefferson against
Kessler Jennings Jennings against Tommy
Kendall as the Mills
Donnell Tesla Perry mr. Pemberton
councillor Richards Kessler by me catch
my block just cuz Lyubov put you a
travel of school to just live off for
yes counselor Shenton counselor Williams
yes but that would only make 30 so there
were 11 babes for one abstention and 19
against
sorry absolutely the correct 10 votes
for one against one absentia than 20
against sorry right
the final amendment have run out pieces
of paper somebody else let's keep track
on this from thank you it relates to the
ring-fencing of business rate income for
green energy schemes just look at all
Adam mr. Bromwich how's the car game
cause of Cleve cuz look Crump mr. Curtis
cuz they're headin counselor fielding
there's a Fleming councillor Foreman
councillor freshly Ian hasn't left
virtually Ginny because the Harris has
Mojave as that hinter Seraphin Tesla
Jefferson Kessler Jennings mr. Junod has
the Kendall pencil Emile's Kessler
O'Donnell Kessler Perry mr. Pemberton
mr. Richards councillor Riley councillor
block after both counselors Shenton mr.
Wally Huggins
thank you so there were 11 votes for and
20 against so again that amendment is
lost
thank you ladies and gentlemen
Thank You officers for that we now move
on to the amendments have failed and
therefore we go back to the original
amendment
the original proposal where I'm
proposing will move straight to a vote
it will be recorded vote again so I'm
going to invite officers to go straight
into a recorded vote does anybody wish
to speak on the budget we are required
to vote as to whether to continue the
meeting continuing the meeting please
raise their hands against any
abstentions thank you it's carried we
will continue the meeting as quickly as
we can right with the amendments are
failed and therefore as opposed to
moving straight on to the vote on the
major budget because I can't walk
because identified in wish to speak on
me budget as House Counsel image so
counsel not for us please how's the
JUnit I just very quickly I just wanted
to comment on the euro bus partly in
response to Council of Bromwich I
welcome that particularly expanding it
to the east of the district because
there is a problem in the east of the
district we don't have a series of
conversations with officers about I just
would recommend to cabinet we think
about how to spend that money
because the take up in the east of the
district is is quite low
the reason it's low is because it's
based in Stratford that's very difficult
because the area the district it takes a
long time to get there but a lot of
conversations with officers about it can
we just look at how that we can make
that money more effective that's just
the one thing I wanted to say I know
castle but we're probably echo that but
we do think about those things in the
east of the district thank you Thank You
counsel counsel forage right then became
the budgets they all say the best
budgets are the most boring budgets now
answer wise that's quite true in this
budget is be boring it's not really
imaginative however as counselors we
ended up the face of fact well this year
our budget is a little bit boring and
not really imaginative in the coming
years we are cannot seriously think
about getting some imagination some
innovation and get very creative on how
we're going to do budgets and thank this
council because the certainty is we know
at the moment we have a black hole in
our finances and we all have nice wish
lists at the same time for our various
Ward's so we are gonna have to have some
serious thinking go into the future
about how we go forward in the finance
of this council and I think it's
important every counselor realizes that
that they need these financial figures
properly ask the questions properly I
know you promise but la will always be
made aware by myself on some things this
time around but we need to be asking a
lot more questions and thinking a lot
more where this money goes thinking
where we are going to end up saving
money and it could end up things like
since I'm the world member coming to a
meeting it's a conference call instead
say transport cost cause of your climate
change policy simple things to more
larger scale of things but everything is
gonna have to be on the table seriously
over the next two years
thank you Kosovo Mitch Council junit I
can't I can't vote for this one and the
main reason is about the green waste and
a few of the other instances however I
did say that there was some good stuff
in there and the you bus and definitely
the climate change one is is very much
close to my heart so I am you know I do
feel strongly about that I know that the
Liberal Democrat proposals have all
fallen however I hope you will see them
as they were meant to be which is
pointers towards where policy might
change I mean two of those four items
for example had no direct revenue
implications and they are things that
you might consider and are used
elsewhere they are about the climate
change one for example as well it might
be an idea that you take on board when
you're looking at your five hundred
thousand because it is applicable for
other items were applicable right across
the district for everybody within the
district so although you are have turned
these down I do hope that with it when
you are talking about the climate change
panel which is now going to be
cross-party and that you're talking
about the five hundred thousand full
climate change you will start to take on
board these some of these things as well
meaning very well-researched policy
proposals to take forward Thank You NASA
Janet
counselor really Hodgins Thank You chair
it was just point of order is counsel
brauch
I just wanted you to know that my
experience and the last six months has
been that's the quality of the officers
in this established network for
Stratford district council means at
every level at which they are working
shows imagination and innovation thank
you thank you so Twitter Hogan's
councillor crop just very briefly I
think the council should Lobby to remove
the perception that the district council
is a wealthy area he said I do find that
this perception has got the money so we
should give it somewhere else
lovely for Farrah funding for rural
districts we should lobby for more long
term settlements over three to five
years which will create more certainty
in stability and I think the council
should also work with partners more I
didn't speak about the amendment from
the Lib Dems the only issue is that we
need to work more with our partners on
climate change there's one area that was
about planting trees and I think every
district and bora in Warwickshire I'm
the County Council is on about planting
trees which I think if it was done on
the coordinated approach could be done
more efficiently effectively and with
economies of scale so I think we need to
work together on that and several areas
there so become more efficient more
effective and that's be a leader you
know I think being a councillor is being
a leader understanding of the community
and with that perception that from the
advantage from the West Midlands mayor
who wanted us to support hs2 which
I'll go back in and the money could be
used over there but that's another issue
I do find that quite patronizing and
condescending so I think really we need
to stand up straight away
thank you thank you House of Crump
counsel Pemberton a very brief one and
catch the Judy you talked about us
taking this on we will own climate
change this is not our climate change
bond this is your climate change panel
so we as a collective will look at these
things and it'll be you know I just want
to make that point it's not also
anything this stuff we all own it on the
climate change things so we're all in
that's just wanted to make that point
that it's a all of this thing
thank you Cassidy a climate change
officer we've declared a climate change
emergency Thank You counsel writing
counselor factually briefly working
together as a CAD counselor and as a
town councillor already trying to work
from Town Council point of view and I'm
sure there are lot of parishes as well I
think parishes and
don't Thank You counsel factually
counselor Harris Thank You chair I just
want to take us back to what counselor
Wally Hagan these counselor Brahmaji
touched upon about innovation about the
goodness and greatness of the offices of
this council capacity is the issue I
think here the council is extreme trim
to the bone I think over the years for
saving money so therefore going forward
they're limited and I think that was
part the problem around communication
but going forward that were have these
higher expectations we've got these
harder decisions I think we should feed
in there somewhere that somebody start
looking at capacity in freeing up the
capacity or where we could support the
officers more to help generate more
outward-looking
rather than head down because everyone's
buried in work and more innovation and
more support I just wanted that no
teacher Thank You councillor Harris to
any other councillors wish to talk on
this motion in which case I'm going to
invite as Tony Jefferson proposed the
budget which was introduced by councilor
Harvey but to adjust as proposed did the
council Jefferson now concludes the
debate on this item the issues that are
being raised I have to say that this
could be a first for any council meeting
I think as we said we will have to be
innovative we will have to start
thinking outside the box because we do
have some real challenges coming down
the track
I'd also like to pick up the point
that's being raised about working with
others
of specifically climate change with
Warrick District Council we have already
agreed in principle that we would work
with them they are recruiting a climate
change officer at the moment and theirs
is for a salary of 80,000 now that is
quite interesting because I don't think
there is any point reinvented the wheel
I think we should see to it like you to
see one absolutely right not all parts
of the district are affluent and I think
it is very unfortunate that people
actually think the whole district is
affluent and it's very unfortunate that
a lot of funding is ring-fenced
that we cannot access that is definitely
something that I think in terms of about
spending for District Council's yes so
with that can I propose that we accept
the recommendations on page 30
recommendations one to five
we've had that concluding statement from
the leader we have five recommendations
I'm going to invite the leader as to
whether he wishes to the action on block
or whether he wished a recorded vote for
each item we therefore will have a
recorded vote on items 1 to 5 taken
together
that process Thank You chairman
indications on page 30 of the agenda
I'll be asking whether you support
boating for against or for Adam
counselor counselor plumage can just
look Cargill because I cleave cuz the
Crump tender Curtis Custer head in comes
the field in counseling counsel of
Pullman pencil eventually Ian and
supposedly Jenny Tesla Harris
cuz the Harvey cuz they hinge your
Seraphin Kessler Jefferson Kessler
Jennings castle of JUnit counselor
Kendall because the mills
O'Donnell there's the Perry Kessler
Pemberton Custer Richards Kozlov Riley
castle rock castle of wolf Delta Shenton
and the castle of Wally Huggins thank
you
okay thank you very much there was 21
votes for with 10 abstentions and
therefore the recommendations are caring
thank you thank you very much I
therefore move on to item 10 which the
treasury management management strategy
invite councillor Trevor Harvey as
finance and assets portfolio holder
George chooses item Thank You mr.
chairman there's an annual requirement
under the guidance issued by the
ministry for housing communities and
local governed for councils to draw up
and approve an annual investment
strategy that meets the Chartered
Institute of public finance and accounts
ease treasury management code of
practice this council's proposed
treasury management - strategy for the
forthcoming year was set out on pages 93
2 1 1 9 of the papers considered by the
Cabinet on 10th of February 20 20 at
that meeting I drew attention of members
of the cabinet to just one aspect of the
strategy on page 1 1 3 members of the
cabinet saw that the expectation for
investment returns in the immediate
future remained low and given the
uncertain times in which we live the
prospect of any rise in investment
returns was both uncertain and modest
the proposed capital and investment
strategy for the period twenty twenty
twenty one to twenty twenty four twenty
five was set out on pages 121 236 of the
papers considered on the 10th of
February that proposal provided the
framework within which it is intended
the council should make its capital and
investment decisions over the next five
years on the assumption that councillors
have been able to familiarize themselves
with these papers and subject to any
questions they may have
I ask that approval is given to
recommendations 1 to 4 as set out in the
paper
now before the cabinet
the council thank accounts - Harvey are
you proposing you all treasury
management strategy can you confirm yes
can I have a seconder counsel Jefferson
right which case are you from the
debates does anybody wish to raise any
items on treasury management strategy as
identified
yes counselor junit I'm not got any
objections and I do note that addressing
the climate change emergency is well and
truly in discomfort in that so I'm happy
with anybody else have any comments they
wish to raise in which case I have
there's two questions we this is not a
recorded vote the council Harvey are you
happy for the three recommendations to
be taken on block
yes thank you all those in all those in
are we agreed with Treasury manager
strategy the Gannett will move on to
number 11
I'm Trevor Harvey is - NASA's portfolio
Hulbert reduces item Thank You mr.
chairman in conjunction with considering
its budget for the forthcoming year the
council is required by the sip
Prudential code to set Prudential
indicators that ensure that it's capital
and investment plans are affordable
prudent and sustainable the paper in
support of an agenda item 11 sets out
the factors that the council through its
section 1 1 5 officer is required to
take into account when considering the
affordability in its particular
circumstances of its intended capital
expenditure over the period of the
medium-term financial strategy and the
affordability of the capital financing
requirement to which this extended
expenditure may give rise councillors
will have noted that the intention to
incur expenditure of 5 million pounds in
relation to the materials recycling
facility and the financing requirement
to which this will give rise the section
1 5 one officer has satisfied himself
that the terms associated with this
course of action will in his view meet
the relevant requirements counselors are
therefore asked to approve the
recommendation set out on page 42 of
this report that the proposed Prudential
indicators for the forthcoming year be
approved Thank You mr. chairman seconded
mr. chair thank you in which case I open
the item up for debate
does anybody wish to raise any issues
like no comments whatsoever off well
done comes to Harvey we do not have to
worry about this being taken on block
because it's only one recommendation are
we agreed with this item
thank you in which case we now move on
to item 12 and you have a separate piece
of paper which would not include in your
agenda of original agenda papers and I'm
asking councillor Jefferson to introduce
item 12 it's a formal approval of the
formal counsel Tax Resolution as set out
in Appendix 1 you will notice that this
includes town and parish councils
Warwickshire County Council the peace
and crime Commissioner District Council
so it is a matter for all the
calculations are there in the appendix -
so all I can say is I recommend that we
approve the formal council text
resolution at appendix one do you have a
second done Thank You councillor Harvey
right you heard the proposal from the
leader does anybody wish to raise any
items counselor junit just that we'll be
abstaining on block thank you this is
through the normal procedure but thank
you for your comments
right as there are no comments comes
Justin I assume you don't want to
conclude the debates on this item
thank you in which case I'll invite the
chief detective to carry out a recorded
vote so we'll vote in relation to the
recommendation on the supplementary
paper to approve the formal council tax
resolution appendix one councilor kettle
mr. budge
that's the field in castle Fleming
councillor Foreman just look freshly ear
as the freshly Jenny mr. Harris
there's the Harvey Tesla hence your
Seraphin owsla Jefferson absolute
Jennings June it has the Kendall have
some meals
oh don't know it's Lipari that's the
Pemberton councillor Richards Riley
Kalibak thank you both
[Music]
okay so chairman there was 20 thank you
very much
we therefore can now move on to new area
the agenda item 13 nurse emotional
closeable campaign and our rights
attorney Jeff Simmons legal counsel for
introduces item I will be mercilessly
brief chair of the cabinet are
recommending to counsel that the
military some motion be supported I
therefore propose we support the notice
of motion do you have a second up counts
of Hamilton does anyone wish to speak on
this item coastal flood Veera support of
the council
thank you can surf actually comes
pemberton Jewish respond to that
Jefferson as soon as possible counselor
fradulent thank you it does anybody else
have any issues comes to Rolf rock thing
mr. chairman
thankfully Bank check I just wanted to
thank the cabinet for that it's like the
same things I said at the cabinet make
thank you for the support and as counts
to Pendleton sit at the time we can all
work together on this and I think it's
marvelous so thank you very much
Thank You Council Rock any other anybody
else wish to raise any items can
suggested you have any concluding
comments no chair in which case we'll
move straight to the vote are we agreed
on this item thank you we therefore move
on to item 14 the pay policy statement
so now invite counsel attorney jeff
sooners neither counsel to introduce
aside some
thank you the pay polishes told on I
think the senior officers are going to
be needing the room at this point
Georgia Georgia
right party time
right ladies remember call to order
please
right cancel Jefferson with now just for
the record we've had victories or
interest by senior officers and
therefore they've left the room and
therefore Caroline Nash is the senior
officer present counsel Jefferson we
liked from chooses item Thank You chair
a matron of the employment of
Parliament's Committee was held on the
20th of January 2020 which the following
item is being considered and referred to
council for determination you will see a
summary narrator on page 45 and 46 the
entire document comes to 13 pages which
I'm sure we have all read and I just
like to say we're recommending to
Council at the pay policy statement as
appended to the agenda report be adopted
for the period of 20 20 21 do you have a
second up Thank You councillor Pemberton
does anybody wish to raise this any
items in this debate no comments at all
I assume which case are we agreed to
accept the proposal
thank you could somebody invite the
senior officers back in
therefore move onto the couch - Juna yes
I was going to actually mention missing
this thing but I knew that there's
mention of Roman Ulster is mentioned as
one of the outside bodies I'm not sure
on it as the part of the council but I
do have brochures here if anybody's not
visited please come along and help
support we are a charity Thank You
councillor JUnit is that the interest
you need to declare or not you need to
declare an interest in that or not I am
the chairman of the charity thank you
Upendra you're seconding the proposal
from Cal suggestion thank you
does anybody else have any comments they
wish to raise on this item cut spending
acknowledged is about to come members
will also know that the Chairman's
report was issued today and is on your
deck thank you we now move on to
councilor counsels questions therefore
and the first question is from
councillor fielding fielding you've had
a response to your question do you have
yes I am concerned about the business to
do with parking and highways I know
highways is nothing to do with the
district but we have got to get the
contractors cars off the road as quickly
as possible because it's the narrowness
of some of the roads in the villages we
have buses horses bicycles and
everything else and it really does make
a liability and I note that there is
more effective than me what is that and
can I have details of it please
also the comment with regards to
agricultural land it is as polluted as
brownfield land with regards to asbestos
sprays fuels etc and by releasing it it
does mean that it can be social housing
the question please review that Thank
You counsel
counterfeiting I'm satisfied with the
replies that we've given you with
regards to looking at brownfield sites
they are robust in their very statements
they cannot comment here there's no
specific question here relating to a
specific site and we are saying here
very specifically and I can guarantee
that we are looking at construction
management plans and make them more
robust I'm looking at several ways in
which we can make them more visible so
that there's less room for if you like
non-compliance thank you Thank You
councillor fielding you have the second
question do you have a supplementary
question that it's coming forward under
the climate change task force however it
is important that we take a view as
quickly as possible with regards to
recharging of vehicles in the
countryside it can't always be done with
regards to power points in garages or on
four courts a lot of people park on the
road and we've got to take a view on
this an interesting comment made in the
Telegraph was that a lot electric cars
now when they break down they break down
suddenly and they are causing a problem
on the motorways because they can't be
pushed to one side so we've got to take
a view on how we get around these
problems thank you
can I just remind councillors the
supplementary question does need to be a
question to the portfolio holder it is
an opportunity for statement okay
councillor Edmund you've received a
response from councillor Barker do you
have a supplementary question Thank You
chair Thank You councillor and
councillor Jenny for actually
Kancil Ian frigidly how do you have so
much question Curtis is absent cants the
joke leave do you have a supplementary
question to response enjoy good and cord
your relationships with colleagues
discussing this and many other issues
with the County Council and moving
forward
thank you sir all because we're all
caucus is is absent we therefore move on
to point 10 counselor Adam you had a
response from the council do you have a
supplementary question yes I do
this issue is ongoing and is causing
problems across the district below
including in my ward
given that the infrastructure allowance
album cannot support any further
increase in this was a fundamental
aspect that this app in its inception
can you please ask the leader of council
to approach the leader of work county
council to discuss this now a very
urgent issue to find us with the
resolution as possible thank you very
much
thank you Thank You counsel Hamilton
councillor Juliet you had a response do
you have a question yes I do
consider Ian one three four three two
which is the international standard
coming bioplastics and please leis with
the County Council and the industrial
composting plants because this
international standard has been in place
for a bioplastic for some years and they
should be taking a counter it so could
you please make sure that en then three
four three two international standard is
being discussed when bioplastic is
plastics is being considered but you
want to respond counselor actually
European norm one three four three two
and we have had a look at this issue
especially with regard to things like
composite of all compostable cups the
problem lies in as you've probably
identified that assets our process runs
on an eight-week cycle and the twelve
weeks
[Music]
now counselor Rock you've had a response
to your question do you have a
supplementary question to Castle Harry
yes Thank You mr. chairman I think
castor paper her answer this is a
question about enforcement relating to
HS 2 because there is a gulf in the
ability to enforce against any
infringement against the acts of
parliament that granted planning
permission for ages 2 and I do thank her
for around sir a mink on chat would
generally rise and she correctly points
out I do attend the meetings in fact I
miss the last one because I was ill and
so I have had conversations and the
emails we journey arrived
however the question I respectfully
point actually felt went to one
particular aspect which is could we
coordinate with other local authorities
along the route and perhaps talk to
those because I have the same potential
problems as we do when they do the wrong
things dealing with HS to to correct
those they've got a very long response
period for putting anything right you
know 21 days if somebody's got the wrong
tree down our Authority and other
authorities are very good at enforcement
HS to or not so it's worth liaising with
those other local authorities along to
see if we could establish a common way
of doing that and let's all get together
and lobby our respected MPs which I
respect we're already doing but let's
see if we can collaborate together doing
that there is a group of local
authorities that have the same concern
Thank You councillor Rock feel very
diligent and pointed question which I
concur with you and as you know I'm very
keen to work particularly with Jeremy
right because the hs2 goes through a
large section of his ward
I think it's pertinent for us to work in
a collaborative way with other
authorities
but maintaining that we act within our
own enforcement and the guidelines set
develop within our local authority but I
think a collaborative approach on such a
major infrastructure project is sensible
thank you
Thank You Council Perry I can't stop
Adam you've got a response students off
miniature question yes thank you chair I
appreciate the response apart from
leader of the council and approaching
the police and crime Commissioner on the
increased resource that may be required
around potential stresses from hs2
construction is welcomed but I would add
that given that our Community Safety
team work closely with the police and
communities and other local authorities
would you please ensure that this matter
is raised with them to ensure that any
future resource is allocated
appropriately and efficiently please the
place in crime Commissioner thank you
both counselors high def will move on to
costa brava CH you have you had a
response to your question your mentoring
question yes disappointed here that the
potential extra council meters regarding
climate change and finance to you after
question would you be willing to consult
other councillors with all the other
focus of these issues
council famiglia Council of Romick I
think we've just set up a Climate Change
panel with the agreement of the leader
of the opposition and the scrutiny I
think we will need to see how well this
works because this will actually
consider most of the climate change
issues and will actually report back
through scrutiny which will do improve
pre scrutiny on it to the cabinet so
there is now in terms of climate change
I think a very thorough process in place
to look at the issues of climate change
in terms of Finance I will just say I
think we picked up a number of issues we
need to tighten up on given the green
waste issue we've dealt with I think as
and when we get a four year settlement
we will look at that and then say
actions we need to take as a result one
thing I would say is I think the inputs
we have had this term of being
significant I think they will be even
more significant in future Thank You
counsel counsel Roberts you have a
second question this situation as noted
on this question on this issues we
didn't bring into the question but we
need to bring
thank you very much the district is
going to become a very tricky issue we
monitor the situation and take whatever
action we think is appropriate I would
have to say that the actions thank you
it was noted that we would have a water
fountain on the playground I was
wondering if there is a timetable for
installation of that water fountain on
the playground especially as the Easter
holiday school holidays are coming on us
given the latest weather patterns
counselor factually your hopes may be
dashed I don't know I will find out
rummage in some ways leader because as
many cups made noticed I have a lack of
training hours now I'm not spoken about
this properly before there's a few you
know that's possible child three years
ago who was subsequently in the past we
worked in past few weeks been diagnosed
with some very serious problems which
I've had to deal with because I haven't
been out to get over to trainings in
particular because of various issues
regarding now I've tried to work in with
Democratic Services Committee on this
valve to try and divulge too much
personal information it appears that I
will have to do that now as I'm dealing
a very big problem as well but the crux
of this is I noticed a source some
online training potential which will
probably help me get a lot of my hours
in I think me mail of responding that
three weeks ago about no response path I
offered last region how turn to come
into the history council office itself
and actually do some training while
stuff forget proper child who's going
through a lot of problems no response
from that
very personal information as to why I've
been to various meetings rather than
people trying to actually engage me
directly neither can we get some because
this is personal issue and when a
request is the leader comes back to our
outside the form of this meeting this is
a personal issue
so lastly just come back to you directly
if you don't want cosa cargo Thank You
chairman leader given the incredibly
generous offer by the Chinese to build
hs2 for us not only quicker but cheaper
are you going to love Parliament to make
sure that this happens
Thank You councillor Cargill
I'm not sure
now in which case we will move on to
point 18 and I just ask members to note
the financial summary at the back so
that you will feel aware of the clinic
of the council's financial position and
then going to move on to one final issue
I've been asked by counsel a holiness
and business to raise one issue
[Music]
introduced it council way to help into
some item urgent business county lines
awareness raised county lines awareness
event which is taking place on the 10th
of March in Stratford at the Stratford
Playhouse and other streets county lines
is a criminal business model run by
organized crime groups which exploit the
vulnerable adults and children to export
drugs from urban cities into rural towns
the model relies on coercion
exploitation and violence the event aims
to increase awareness around how young
people and vulnerable adults can become
exploited into county lines activity the
event is two hours long and will consist
of an input form or extra police about
the latest picture and activity taking
place I'll urge you therefore to attend
to either the two sessions I've got
leaflets here if you collect on your way
out and really it's not to miss so that
you can be of service to those that you
represent thank you but clearly county
lines and drug abuse of young children
is something which I think concerning
constructive day
that will go declare the meeting closed
at 1754